what's up everybody it's your girl jess
and welcome to episode i don't know of
the pre-game
welcome guys so today i am your host i
know i don't look like sarah or pearl
sorry i did not transform into them but
um today we're going to be talking about
an interesting topic but before that
make sure you like comment subscribe
share this video share the link with
people so they can check it out and
enjoy the conversation that we're having
today also
if you have seen
this video or any other video on this
channel more than once then we got beef
like real beef like beef burger patty
beef so today i have some special guests
with us so we're gonna go around and you
all can say your name where you're from
and
we'll go if you've ever been cheated on
so we'll start here
all right my name
my name is teolini
uh mine's from hackney and now i've
never been cheated on all right
um i guess it's me right yeah
what's going on everyone uh my name is
jt aka king babs
um i'm originally from congo uh raised
in hackney
and yes i have been cheated on
hi i'm chamari i'm from florida and
technically yes
i'm kirsty i'm originally from jersey
but i live in london and yes i've been
cheated on
hey amiri trinidad tobago london west
london all over the gap
i don't know if i've been cheating on
you get me like these girls are too good
at it like i'm just being
i'll just be real i don't know i don't
know yo my name is peace over um
i'm from catford to southeast london
originally from congo as well so
and uh
i to my knowledge i don't know if i've
been cheered on i don't know to be
honest
all right
so
before you go away
[Music]
tell us so today what we're going to be
kidding
is is difficult we'll we'll come back to
you we'll come back to me so my first
question
if you're um
would you consider cheating would you
consider it cheating
if
you're in the
talking stage with someone but you both
have
made it
exclusive that you two are just talking
to each other
yes yes
no wait are you mutually
mutually exclusive
yeah like you're you're not talking to
no one else and he's not talking to
anyone anybody else it's like you two
but you just haven't made it facebook
official yet is that
it's a ross or raw
whatever
because from the moment that
you have the conversation mm-hmm from
the moment you have the conversation
that okay this is what we're going to be
doing
um we're talking but i don't want like
i'm not going to talk to no one else i'm
not going to get to know no one else
you're not going to get to know someone
else so
i feel like why are you stepping out to
then go and meet other people like is
eva
you're on the streets
you're on the streets when you're at
home like you have to pick you know what
i mean that's what i feel anyways i feel
like it is cheating yeah i'm with that i
don't care like it doesn't matter if
you're saying oh we are like on facebook
oh in a relationship it doesn't matter
once you're saying oh i want to be with
you and we're like we're together
then you're together like it's
it's from there
yeah so i agree to an extent where if
you guys say you're together then cool
like if you guys are talking and say all
right you've got made the
the um agreement like all right we ain't
talking to nobody
all right then
if he goes up on the boundaries there or
she goes up on the boundaries there then
it's cheating however i don't think is
technically cheating because you're not
on an item not to say that it's not
wrong because you have betrayed whatever
agreement you have made
but
technically speaking
and well in my opinion anyway it's not
cheating but you do cross a boundary do
you cross the line and that will have
the similar effects of cheating
go ahead i was going to say man try
be politically correct like you're gonna
say like you've been police i'm trying
to say but i'm just kidding
have you have you got a wedding ring on
no
all right so when when it comes to girls
like getting men yeah they don't
necessarily go out and chirps and do all
of that men are just continuously so
you're you're on the market still
technically you're on the market still
you're you want to restrict men so men's
not on the market still no i would
advise men to stay on the market bro
until you're not in a fully relationship
yeah where you know that you could
demand stuff as the man in the
relationship you could tell a listen i
don't want you on instagram and all of
that doing all of that extra stuff i
don't want you doing all of this stuff
until then just let her do her things
like let me be a woman
i think it's just not in control you're
saying parameters telling her i don't
want you to be on instagram i don't i
don't want it
100 know what they want in a
relationship they will tell you exactly
so
bro so there you go that's when you come
together she's advertising
i like this i like that all right boom i
don't want you doing this if the guy or
girl is willing to do something bro why
are you why are you saying something is
she your goal oh oh just like no no
because you're sitting down like so many
rules no no no no no no no no no this is
about yeah no i'm saying okay if you're
not sitting down those rules then why do
you have to set the why is she setting
the rule for you not to like
it's beyond me bro like
okay you all right you're what she likes
about you is the fact that you go out
and you'll be able to chat together and
you know i'm saying you're a bit swaggy
the moment you just tape turn that off
you could turn that off for about a
month bro you're not the same you're not
you're not gonna you're not gonna say
you're like rock can i chat together
still like yeah bro you're not gonna get
the same role but why
mute your understanding isn't it between
the pair of you what you actually want
and establish that and if you're saying
you both want exclusivity what does that
actually mean i was seeing someone
recently and he told me we were
exclusive but i had no idea
i had no idea
i'd given my number to someone and he
got really upset about it but then he
was engaging with women on instagram so
i'm like well did he tell you he wasn't
exclusive
he he told me we were exclusive about
three months then but his exclusivity to
him is different to what i would say
perfect he's basically saying that i can
go out but exactly yeah yeah that was it
but that's right though that's right
because it's like you can't say we're
exclusive and we didn't agree that we're
exclusive
i'm saying we're exclusive so you do
stuff that don't make you feel like
you're out there still available on the
strip like with a for sale signs still
on you like listen hello was your
instagram deleted yeah but it's the for
sale signing still on you the guy
no if i'm
but men are still going to church you so
while that's happening you have what 20
instagrams a day of men saying oh come
well forget that guy bro look the ball
look the bmw didn't know you're getting
options available to you yeah i have no
options available to me because i have
to be the person that goes out and chat
together
not necessarily not in this day and age
one at a time allowed just to speak so i
agree with you not not this day and age
by far
you will men i feel like yes there are
some females who have dms running up and
but nowadays
women aren't going to wait for men to
come up and chat to them they're about
to step out slide into the dms as well
but is that would you consider that an
insecurity if you're worried about men
going to her dms because
as for women that would be considered an
insecurity if you're worried about women
sliding to his into his dms because
they can slide all they want they can
slip and slide water slide whatever but
as long as they don't engage with it
it's fine just you're not allowed you're
not allowed to get away with that i like
how you segue the way hey you don't just
want to say she's segued away after
making a point no no no i'm going to
retract you i'm going to go back to your
main point
i'm what i'm saying here is basically
women
you you you always have this little
they're just i'm not really interested
okay when that guy that you really like
like when drake comes in the instagram
it's not like i'm not interested like
wait hold on a minute wait what who who
like you're waiting for that guy if it's
the right guy that comes in wow this guy
is here
i'm monkey branch in a way
i'm not saying every girl
i'm not saying every girl but this is a
normal tendency of girls and we allow it
to happen as men because we're like you
know what we've got we do our things
like whatever you i'm saying but i'm
saying don't pretend like you don't
monkey branch
hype hypergamy is is real bro
you look monkey branch bro so and we
allow it because as men i'm the person
on the other side saying hey that brain
you're getting it bro you know what i'm
trying to say what do you mean love it
bro you've nev you've never you've never
chatted to a girl
asked me have you never chatted to a
girl yeah that was
i wouldn't say in a relationship with
another man but she was talking to
another bra
yeah did that stop you from talking to
her no exactly bro
i i i went again that's my point
i
guess
oh you wanna point okay okay
but you understand what i'm trying to
say though like
it don't stop you no no that's a guy
don't stop us anyway if i tell her if i
tell her listen look up that instagram
she's got no instagram for men to chat
to you that but you don't have too much
you don't have to listen to you but you
know what i have to say to that part
there is like it's it's 20 22 now
doesn't have to listen to you is that yo
regardless if she looks off instagram
she walks on the street nothing i'm
moving to precisely
like in this age so it's a matter of if
you're saying ah she's entertaining all
these other guys gee that means you got
the wrong girl that's how you're not
necessarily if your girl is if your girl
is true to you yeah yeah she ain't
entertaining nothing mandom can still
pull up to her disney fairytale no it's
not even under disney no it's not it's
not even on a disney on a realistic one
yeah
um it's like i go a girl gets moved to
youtube yeah she can get the snap but
then what
like
because girls give out snaps even if
they're in relationships like it that's
that's a fact in it but wait what wait
was it again i said girls give out their
snaps even though speaking to them um
even though if um when they're in a
relationship is that cheating
yeah thank you that's cheating bro wait
wait i'm waiting
i'm staying i'm just stating what
happened i'm not i'm more outgoing yeah
yeah but i'm saying um to conclude my
point is you gotta be you gotta be
realistic in certain situations you
either have to g-check your goal on her
either entertaining um other guys or
giving out snaps
or
not gee
you're saying that she if she ain't got
a snap then you don't need to do that
then that's like so that means you get a
girl so that means you get a girl she
can't have no socials precisely bro why
does she need it bro
if i was a man to validate her ass bro
i'm here to validate it bro
that sounds hella insecure it's not
insecure
would you like would you like your man
to be chirps and girl on instagram
because here's the thing is how you use
it so i think it's cheating if say if
i'm i'm intentionally giving oh like i'm
i'm with next man and i'm saying oh yeah
here's my snap here's my insta blah blah
blah but if people message me i cannot
respond to them like that's their own
problem but do you get something out of
it why do i have to delete my own media
account do you what do you get something
out of it oh get something out of what
of p of men messaging you and you know
exactly so wait so you're saying
i should allow you to keep it so you
could get men to message you that you
don't i'm not allowed to
when you could just delete it and
i and then you know not the only people
on my media page
i'm gonna be so real yeah like i hear
your point in it just the prevention is
better than curing it thank you do you
get what i'm saying however you need to
understand social media isn't just there
to get moved to like separately in a big
in a in its biggest spectrum yeah social
media social media i mean yeah people
move to you but gee there's enough
opportunities that you can get off of
social media now technically speaking
you just blocked off your girl from
um someone let's say your girl was doing
art or music
come on don't do that don't no no no but
jesus
don't do that okay if it's for her
business that's for her business
if it's for if it's for a bathing suit
when she's not even on the beach like do
you know what i mean like what do you
mean like
you're just advertising yourself if
you're an advertiser
where would you break it off at if
you're saying oh like yeah she can have
a business account but not a personal
account not going for it so if it's her
business account i'm like
and and that theory is her business
where would you say no you don't need to
post that because it's her business so
it would still be catered to her brand
no no but okay
is every single girl in london a model
okay it's my instagram it's like it's
for my modelling it's for my business
that's all my candles it's it's for my
it's my aromatherapy it's like my yoga
business
come on like the business is yeah bro
it's like the business is cakes and
candles and flowers and what i think
that's calm
if it's if it's denisha if it's the knee
shot hey pass the pasta look at the shot
if it's a personal page yeah she has the
right to determine whether she wants to
post what is she you can't stop it from
living
and i can't stop
the same way that you wouldn't like for
her yeah to dictate to you like if she
if a girl came up to me like oh yeah
because remember the question she said
if you're if you're still in the correct
way
if she's still in the talking stage yeah
normally you don't have the right to
tell anyone you know you can do this you
can do this because if she came to you
and be like oh we're on the talking
stage this time in the other but i don't
want you to i don't want you to to be
doing everything else that us men do
then you'll become a different different
conversation i 100 get you but what my
point is
you're saying yeah
i'm i can't put any barriers on her when
we're just in the talking stage only
when we're in a relationship so why no
no even putting barriers in your
relationship no i'm saying okay if
you're if you're in a relationship with
a girl yeah there's certain things you
you would um want her to respect in
terms of you as a man in terms of the
relationship true right
and i'm saying those things you don't
expect from other girls that you're not
in a relationship with
that that you're just sleeping with okay
if you're in a relationship you can't
tell you can't tell a girl you're just
sleeping with to take off your instagram
but you can sleep with your yo and love
let you know i'll be with other girls so
what you just you just saw me as a
cheating
right now but to what you said
because that's what you said
[Applause]
before we move on to the next thing
i i understand where you're coming from
with having um
like giving her not restrictions but
letting her know like you can't post his
campaigns out because there are women no
matter who they have as a husband who
they have as a boyfriend that validation
from outside men it it feeds something
yeah i'm not gonna act like i even felt
like oh you're looking at me like felt
good about something because even um
aisha curry
she was talking about steph curry and
how she how he got all this attention
from female fans and she was like i want
attention from male fans it's like how
when you're married to steph curry like
how do you why do you want that
that validation from my outside man when
you're married to him and so i
understand that
it's not just somebody sliding into the
dms it
means something more if the man that
that woman is with isn't feeding the
area into or her life she's going to
find it somewhere else and it may just
be in a little dm here like hey like i
think you're just really pretty this
that in the third i agree with that but
i don't think that in that situation
steph curry and aisha i don't think
steph curry doesn't do everything oh
yeah no no i'm not saying that yeah i
just think personally would that my
opinion seems like you love this woman
bro huh seems like you love this woman
no no no i just think that no i don't
love this woman i just think that she
she's greedy
oh i think she's greedy because really
and truly if you
steph curry is one of the top zero
points
please sorry if curry is one of the top
top one percent guys john decided to if
you've got that speaking if you've got
that um
you should be happy as a woman you
should be happy why why because
i'm going to get him i'm going to get
him i'm going to get it
because tired is 1 [ __ ] man
people why because yeah because yeah
first of all what is he offering us he's
offering her security right he's
offering her a lot of love marriage a
family all of that
she does not need validation from any
other guy
any other guy because he's giving her
all the validations that she needs to
understand so for her because she has
money huh
no they're married right they're married
bro they're married they're married
they've been married okay she
understands what's it he doesn't she
don't need any other validation from no
other man yeah you understand no other
man because he gives her everything that
she needs
i'm assuming do you understand i'm
assuming that he gives her everything
that she needs so for her to say that
she wants
validation from other men like in boxes
and texas or whatever that for me i'll
see that as you're greedy you're
ungrateful
for
something that you're ungrateful for for
the position that you're kind of in it's
not necessarily that it may be that she
has insecurities that she's dealing with
and she hasn't dealt with them prior to
getting in a relationship and past
trauma may have caused her to feel a
certain way with him
you know being who he is and she's not
able to deal with it in a certain way so
she's therefore seeking validation i'm
not saying it's necessarily okay but we
never really know what's going on with
someone and people do struggle a lot
with insecurities especially when
they're dealing with someone who is so
you know high profile who is you know
this amazing person in the press you're
thinking wow i have a lot to live up to
as an individual like how how can i live
up to what society wants me to be
because there's probably pressure on the
other party what can i
say
can i say something to that though
okay so why do women get into
relationships where they're not fully
like ready to get into relationships and
then and then put the the like not blame
but they put the like
that's responsibility not responsibility
but they they attack the the new man
with the stuff the old man did like you
have insecurities here that's for you to
sort out you know what i'm gonna say
like that like that's not my job as a
man to sort out you should be fully in
there invested in what we're going on in
right here
what
what you're saying about the the steph
curry thing here is is this here you
gotta remember as a basketball player
yeah you're like you're traveling
every single day you're this way that
way you know that women are gonna be on
to you yeah so i could understand where
she might feel like oh i don't get the
attention that you know
that
when you say that she should be grateful
when you said that when you when you um
elaborated on it i kind of understand
what you meant i wouldn't say that she's
ungrateful because she wants like
a
piece of his like
um
money she wants to like you know i mean
she wants the money i just think she
wants attention but addiction that he
gets she kind of wants it she wants that
kind of attention
and i think you get enough attention as
as his wife i think like people respect
you because you're steph curry's wife do
you understand but that's steph curry's
wife
but that's enough that's not enough for
some woman exactly but that's what i'm
saying in it so she's kind of greedy but
is that stuff is that steph curry's
problem because he's not enough
just keep it
through that's his responsibility yeah
i'm an athlete so i can't understand the
situation when you're in that position
yeah it's your responsibility
to make
[Laughter]
listen listen it's his responsibility to
make his wife feel secure
because her saying that she's she she
wants validation she probably doesn't
want
the
the amount of women that i know the
stand-up women that i know yeah they
don't want validation from other people
they want it from the man if she's
seeking it from outside it means that mr
curry somewhere somehow you're not doing
your job enough bro to make your woman
feel like secure that's why she's
feeling like oh my
oh thank you he said you got a preacher
that's what she's probably thinking like
oh my gosh like my man's getting all
this attention yeah and it must be nice
are you bro
bro you're you're all are you this guy
is a wolf in sheep's clothing bro what
are you talking about listen listen
women want validation from as much
places as possible bro what do you mean
and then when a girl is like yeah like
this is my man that's not my man's
validation but ten minutes ago he was
like no don't ever delete my instagram
it's like what would you want you want
other man's validation or just your
man's validation that's entirely true i
don't call i don't think would you want
do you adjust your man's validation or
other people's validation because when i
was saying delete instagram i'm giving
you 100 validation i'm working i'm doing
everything i'm hey i'll look after you
i'm right or die boom boom boom just
can't be advertising on for other people
he's like no no i have to be allowed to
advertise so wait do you want my
validation or do you want other man's
validation but she's not put out to the
women i've had my instagram since i was
12. so it had nothing to do with a man
yeah that's what i'm saying she wants
the validation like it's not that she
wants other people but she wants to post
and feel good for herself okay i mean
it's not necessarily
you're doing it for validation
it's other men bro it's other men you
know as a man what men think because
you're a man let's not pretend that gals
know what men think men don't get bro
listen
a little bit we know a little something
yeah you know you're not a loser
you know what i'm saying when man give
that little man that little corner eye
you know that corner yeah bro you know
you get that little slick little thing
when the girl walked it's like okay
you're like i see you you know where
you're at yeah
you know i know i feel like everyone
should just work on this the the
insecurities yeah
so that when you do see your girl
posting because it's like i've been i've
been in situations yeah where
i've when i was younger yeah didn't
quite make it i didn't have nothing yet
dated someone dated someone completely
out of my league and my this this girl
was fine
that fire fine where's she from
you don't know her brother
no i mean like what country what country
i'm in her imagination
where she where she's now
she's married now yeah but other times
no i'm saying where's she from i don't
know wait what she's out of the country
well what country i can't say that yeah
but um keep it close but yeah um
she was completely out of my league
right so
for me at the time it was like all my
days we'll be we'll be walking down the
street yeah
and like
like you might need to stop we were
walking down the street yeah and like
people will be whistling i'm like on my
waistband
i'm holding her hand i'm holding that's
my big man
oh
sorry sir well i was with her um people
would be yeah complimenting her and um
just just just
just doing the most right and at the
start it was it was difficult for me to
handle because i'm thinking like like
why is this happening like i'm right
here like am i invisible or something
like that but then
um after a while i had to tell myself
like look
you're the one that went after this girl
she didn't ask you to come after her
yeah you're the one that went after her
you know when she's fine yeah knowing
that she gets this attention
so you have to work on your own
insecurities in handling that now that
i'm i'm i'm older and i've
i'm doing it right for myself the
situation's flipped now right i've got
uh
[Laughter]
no but seriously um i get people that
like oh my gosh like i like you and
stuff but um i'm scared because you have
all these girls that like that like you
and i'm saying to myself well
that's never that's never no here not
there because
if if i like you and you like me it's my
duty my responsibility to make sure that
you feel special and no one else matters
bro you you speak like you're in the
long room with the girl of your dreams
bro
seriously special it's not a couple you
can't believe that's right though
because thank you
thank you thank you
thank you
like you know you're with someone that
means that at some point in time you've
both had a conversation and established
whatever relationship that you want to
have together you're not like most
people are not what someone is saying
like oh yeah let's be together i think
you're [ __ ] ugly but i'm gonna be
with you no like you you attract you're
attracted to them if you're attracted to
them someone else is attracted to them
and you knew that before you got with
them is you you're not the only one
that's ever
like gazed at them no you knew that they
looked a certain kind of way before you
got with them don't be surprised ah no
one is like oh i'm dating someone that's
ugly you know how they look before you
got with them you're you're choosing to
be with them and you should be confident
enough they pick me we're gonna be
together and roll with that i don't
think the owner should be on me i don't
i don't care if you i don't care if
you're hot i don't care no no no no no
no no give me your phone
at a time
no but wait the thing is you knew that
people were going to be checking for her
the same way that you were checking for
her and people might be checking for you
the same way that she could have been
checking for you the point is if you're
if you're both staying inside of your
relationship
why does it matter what who who's trying
to trip at her like you're saying
because you know that if she's your
woman and you really like you have faith
in your relationship you know that she's
going to value you she's not stepping
out to look at the next man head hear my
dick caught me
check this out die cut you know that was
there
eric
learn from himself do you want to be in
a relationship with a man that has no
boundaries for you
what do you mean
yeah what does this mean
do you want to be in a relationship
where the man has no boundaries for you
you're free to do whatever you want yeah
he says you can't do this you can't do
it
no no no wait what
i didn't say that i'm saying do you want
to be in a relationship where a man has
no values for you that's a yes or no
question she should have her own values
no all right so you're saying no though
but we're gonna create boundaries
together i'm not saying oh like oh do
whatever you want to because at the end
of the day like i said you're you're
coming together as a team to create a
bond as a team i understand that but i'm
saying if you're with me
let
when you come into like terms of the
relationship the relationship because
you're saying that you know they said oh
we want to be together so
we've discussed how we want to establish
our relationship in this you've
discussed no
because you're saying you're saying my
my my views are invalidated because
you're saying i can't tell you what to
do because that seems like i'm being
controlling trolling but your your
things what you put on me i have to take
fully 100
knowledge when the two people start a
relationship they say together what is
going to work for them they create the
boundaries together it's not it's not
just gonna be uh i'm your dictator no
like i'm not saying that the man can't
be in charge like because i
the man should take charge like that's
that will work for me so it's not that
dictatorship no no it's not upset
it's not like okay so okay you want me
to be in charge but you don't want me to
hear you come on you know what not there
there's a difference because i'm
demanding every er my every move and i
didn't say i didn't say that i just said
you can't even you're asking me and then
you're not letting me answer no okay
okay so there's a difference between
there's there's a difference between
saying okay babe i think you should do
this and saying nah you're only going to
do this and i'm not letting you do
anything else because listen i you can
say what you want me to do and i i can
follow suit i can happily follow suit
but if you're looking after my every
move or whatever you don't trust me why
am i going to be with you you're saying
you're basically saying it's how i say
and not what i say
you just said a lot of things is how you
say your words just now is basically if
i come to you and say babes i don't
really agree with like you know what i'm
saying don't i'm that's not really
necessarily what i said it's better than
saying babes i don't want you to do that
no no no and i'm saying
okay i'm not saying how to say it a
couple establishes their
listen to what i'm saying let me learn
let me land let me learn i'm not saying
how to say it i'm just saying
there's certain boundaries in the
relationship with me
that you could either adhere to and you
could be with me or you could not adhere
to and be free as a bird but if you're
with me you're gonna you're gonna be
doing certain rules yeah and i expect
that if you if you are a woman that that
is of some cloth that you're gonna have
some rules that i have to stand by as
well i'm not just i can't just be
willy-nilly doing things that i want to
do because if i want to do what i want
to do i'll be around chatting to every
girl i want to
okay
like there will be there'll be no
restrictions but i'm saying i never went
against what you said because what i
said is they're going to agree on these
boundaries together so it is yes it's a
level yes compromisation
if you acknowledge my boundaries but i
didn't i never said i i said [ __ ] your
boundaries i said we're gonna agree
together so if you're saying i'm gonna
and no because listen i already said it
for me i think the man should be the
leader like that's the traditionally the
man is the leader of the relationship
so
huh no sorry good
but
so
whatever whatever rules we're setting up
in place
i
in theory i'm saying i would agree to
them because i said they're coming
together and agreeing on this i never
said that the girl is saying f you and
everything that you're saying i'm not
going to listen to you you're not my
parent blah blah blah i said they're
going to agree together so you can still
be the leader and i can agree by your
rules i think the skills are more tipped
in the favor of girls in in terms of how
it is in terms of the relationships that
men and women
because you're allowed to wait on
whatever you want but the man is
restricted and what's basically in and
other men okay so in the sense of this
other men like will restrict other men
in terms of okay
[Music]
i get what you're saying men will men
will
check a man before a woman checks a
woman
we're
we're more so
sorry
we're more so beans that
like it's it's vin said multiple times
on the channel like oh if someone asked
like if i asked the girls do i look fat
in this dress nine times out of ten
they're like no girl you think you look
good
and then if i asked a guy friends like
yeah or if a guy has hey like how does
this fit look and if it looks trash
they're going to be like go change go
change that but a woman would be like no
i think if you put some shoes with it
it'll look good
to that is that it's just i think that's
more speaking to them that's more on a
biological standpoint like guys are just
naturally more um straight to the yeah
there's a straight to the point like
we're not there's no need to cap about
two ways where fema are more like if
you've got a problem then you probably
won't know or you will know and no words
have been said yeah
the problem comes hidden hostility
between every problem
though
the problem comes when men are talking
to women because we're straightforward
you don't want a hair straight forward
so should women
so what you're saying is women should
learn to understand how men talk so they
can receive it yeah yeah
it will be better for you
100 it'll be better for you you know
what i have to say to that part there as
well
actually again
women
because that's part of their feminine
energy like guys we're masculine that we
can take that girls don't have a lot of
masculine energy unless she's just
naturally masculine there's masculine
females out there but um but even at
that as a feminine girl or feminine
person like you're gonna take you're
gonna feel a tap away like it's gonna
hit you differently but if you're a guy
and you've got masculine energy you're
not gonna feel the same type of weight
so for you to say a guy should now
convert into being a masculine bro if
she does that and she starts developing
more masculine traits you're not gonna
like it in the long run no no no i'm not
gonna say that she should develop
messages no i'm just going along with
what jess was saying she said uh girls
should understand how men communicate
yeah communicate and speak how do you
understand how a person communicates
i want to talk spanish i would have to
learn how to talk spanish no no
therefore if i were to concede
if i want to if i want to
communicate into a feminine person i'll
learn how i'll have to learn how to
communicate more family-like so that
they can understand check this check
this now yeah if your girl's upset now
yeah and and um she says oh which just
like her answer which just should i read
this um this one or that one or um i
want to go hey i want to go there and
the guy's common sense oh we just got to
do this one that's like oh no this is
that oh she's mad at all she'll turn it
into a next thing for you to destabilize
that situation there you can't come on a
masculine aggro flex like ah um why are
you doing this
no you gotta find a way to neutralize
her energy dan
things are civil
girls like men that are indecisive about
where they're taking their goals
thank you there was no indecisive there
now i'm saying okay the man the man
taking charge is in a response to women
saying we don't like men that are
indecisive about this what i'm trying to
say is how do you take charge it's not
about getting taken charge is taking
place yeah it's how you take charge oh i
get that but what i'm trying to say to
you certain girls like certain things
bro not every girl is the same okay
we're assuming that every girl is the
same every girl is not the same some
girls like men to take charge yeah some
some girls might see a man taking charge
as a man being controlling
certain girls might not see it as
controlling they might just say my man
is taking charge but he knows what to do
he knows to handle it i don't need to do
nothing i'm just here chilling rather i
don't live
i'm taking charge in place i'm saying
it's how you take charge exactly what
your point is you said certain girls
might like this and certain girls might
like that it's how you take charge and
how it applies to the girl that you're
dealing with i want you to elaborate
there's a fine line isn't there there's
a fine line if you're entering into any
kind of relationship with someone it's
about understanding how they are and
then understanding how you are setting
some some as you say boundaries but
within those boundaries there's
compromise any partnership whether it be
a relationship a friendship there's
always going to be compromise like you
might not like something they do you
know you might not like some and vice
versa you know so it's about
understanding and working together if
you really like someone you'll make it
work because at the end of the day we're
all different but you cannot we cannot
be telling people what to do we can't do
that it's not our right to tell someone
what to do but what we can say is do you
know what i'm not too happy about that
mm-hmm and then we can work on it
together oh i agree with that
chill bro true i agree with that
i grew that but
but i don't think i don't think it is
telling somebody what to do i don't
think it's that at all fab me i would
never tell anybody what to do yeah if
you want to because remember
women control sex men control
relationships right so if you want to be
in a relationship with me
you have to speak to them you have to
abide by my house rules you understand
how everyone everyone has house rules
cool you're coming in as the vice
president of this house call me you can
send your house
your sergeant you can set your advice
you can set some of the rules that you
want as well do you understand what you
do
michelle obama i'm the president for
barack obama i'm the president here if
you want a relationship with me you have
to come on my flex and that's cop if you
don't if you don't that's fine i i
absolutely
when you start this relationship is for
both of you to agree it's not that the
woman is not going to like say i'm the
leader is that you're both agreeing to
the terms of whatever that's why that's
why sorry can i just finish so you can't
say to someone you can't say to someone
as well
you've got to delete your instagram what
we need to understand is why you're
saying can you delete your instagram and
get to the core routine
what is the issues there is it because
previously something's happened to
traumatize you
right into i do agree and i've been
cheated on through instagram but that
doesn't mean that i would say to someone
that i'm pursuing delete your instagram
because you want to build trust there
you you can't control what someone does
you need to let people and allow people
to have the flexibility to be who they
want to be and the true colors will come
from that you have to have trust if you
put boundaries up by saying and when i
say boundaries is controlling that and
saying you can't do this that's not a
relationship that is a dictatorship you
need to have the trust there okay
honest question yeah if your brother was
a thief would you leave him in your room
with all your money and jewels and stuff
with you
alone
your brother was a thief you love your
brother so you admire no no i'm asking
her your brother is a thief your brother
yeah you love him you admire him you've
seen him grow up you've watched him you
you know what i'm saying you look cute
together when you go out to fun fairs
that's your brother would you leave him
the thief in a room with your stuff your
money inside the open safe but what
you're saying here is comparing it to
someone who's previously cheated and
then i'm getting in a relationship with
them who's cheated on instagram no no
listen because you are because you're
saying your brother's a thief and you're
leaving him alone so you're there is a
comparison is saying you're dating
someone who's previously
cheated are you going to allow them to
have instagram that's what you're saying
no that's not that's not that's not what
i'm saying that's not what i'm saying at
all it is you've created a you've
shifted the goal post to say what i'm
saying how
yes or no question and what she's done
instead of allowing me to elaborate how
i wanted to just where i've seen this
point bro you've went ahead you've went
ahead and determine what answer you've
had
yes or no would you leave your thief
brother
inside of a room with all your your safe
open with all your money in it it's not
a yes or no can i say thank you very
much so
so there's a problem there's there's
there's a issue that you're having
between yourself where you're fired in
between trusting your brother or between
leaving the thief brother inside of a
room with your your safe i'm saying to
you it's not that i don't trust you i'm
saying to you the the more that you are
available on instagram with the same
pics that you had when i saw you is
gonna be another man like me coming
after you and i'm saying okay if you
want to have the for sale sign on the
car okay cool we could just be and i
will not take you seriously but if you
want me to take you seriously and get
off the game where i don't
bother no other girls i don't chirps no
girl i say listen i'm dedicated for you
you have to be dedicated for me you're
you're equivalent of me chirps and girls
is you being available to be chirps
in the house can i ask you something i'm
not saying be locked in the house so i'm
just saying avoid certain things
you made a very valid point just like do
you know what i mean like you you found
her like that yeah and
what do you mean and that's what okay
due to it i found her single she just
remains no no no no
you just said yeah there's gonna be men
going to like the same kind of post that
attracted me to you yeah yeah meaning
that you found her like that right so
and you found her like that you accepted
her like that as she is bro she accepted
you as a person that chirps gal bro so
should you continue
should you continue
how would anyone get
all right all right can i
wait wait hold on
wait hold up
let me speak let me speak
let me speak let me speak that is so
unfair because again i am the one that's
chirps in you so okay i'm gonna chirps
you yeah you're thinking i'm the first
you're the first person of chirps and
you're wait hold on hold on
as a girl
all right i'll check all right i'll
change it are you thinking i'm you're
the first person i've chirped
yeah no i never i've never trust anyone
yeah i have no skill in chirps in but
i'm just so good at chirps in you that
you like me no so you think that i've
been chasing other girls right obviously
obviously so i'm thinking that you're
being churched by other men right
because you're nice you're beautiful
right yes
wait so should i continue be you being
available or should i take you off the
market but it's not just wait can i can
i ask a question
right but okay okay all right
all right how many how many
how many dm's have you had this week yo
i don't count them right and how many
people have stopped you this week
how many people have shown thank you
very much i don't need to answer that
one she could count how many people have
stopped her but she can't count how many
videos she's had right come on bro
instagram there's a guy in new york
that's messing with you i've seen your
instagram like rob boom i got i've got
the bentley there i've got
if you've asked the question allow her
to answer and then you'll you'll be able
to speak yeah yeah
i'm not being funny but i'll walk down
the street and i'll get attention
i'm sure it's the same for a lot of
people we'll get attention i go to the
gym i'll have guys approach me at the
gym come on i'll be in sainsbury's i'll
have someone approach me in sainsburys
it's exactly the same thing you can't
stop someone from being approached it's
not their fault if someone comes up to
them approach them and it's exactly the
same with instagram and you need to
have that respect and trust that they're
not gonna
engage and not gonna act on it and
here's my here's my response to that are
you on inside of sainsbury's walking
with your bathing suit on
no but i'm on the beach with my baby
are all girls on this on the beach with
their bathing suit on on instagram hold
on can i all right bro is it broken
so this this can't work because the
reason why i asked your question is for
you to think about something before i
lay my conclusion down if you're gonna
avoid what the obvious answer is then
it's not gonna work i'm asking you do
most girls have revealing pictures on
instagram
i i don't know
that's a yes
thank you very much thank you very much
for being true
most girls have revealing pictures on
instagram you're not going to be walking
down to sainsbury's wearing the certain
pic
certain times i'll chirp scared to be
like listen let me see your instagram
boom ah is that what is that what the
thing's saying yeah all right cool boom
all right i could talk to you do you
know that instagram is not real life
right all right can i say michael i know
this but
girls can't avoid this bro because this
is their big this is their biggest this
is their biggest of um thing where they
get the most people that chirps that
where they get their most man from in
2022 and you what men are saying to them
listen you can't have that and they're
saying what later but i'm not taking
away
like my my main option thing bro like
and i'm saying to you okay wow all right
you're on instagram or on instagram
it doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter that my instagram is private it
does mount no because i get so many
requests it doesn't mean i have to let
them in you get how many requests a lot
i have thank you very much there you go
yes
how many two over two thousand there you
go two thousand men it's not stopping
you outside
yo yo hold on hold on can i ask my
question now because i've been chilling
here for a little bit now i've been
patient i've been patient come on bro um
but what i'm saying is yeah first to
double back because we've we've gone a
long way um you started off your first
question to um kirsty was um would you
think you're cheated would you leave a
cheating brother um
yeah yeah yeah would you say
brother a fever inside the reason why i
think she's like oh is um your in
comparison is cheating um is because
you've already stated that a narrative
you've come in with a person with a
narrative he why is it not your brother
would you leave your brother because if
you want to make the equivalent is would
you leave would you trust this person
your partner or because
as opposed to your brother now you're
saying this cheating on this um leaving
brother you've already put a narrative
on the guy from the jump yeah but he
hasn't stole from you yet no but you
still put a narrative on the brother so
therefore wait wait wait therefore if
you want to put in comparison it has to
be equal you have to put a you now have
to put a narrative on this other partner
that you want to now deal with so it
being a cheat and thieving i don't know
killer
the other partner has to have a
narrative as well for it to be equal
number one number two is yeah
um this thing about you got with
instagram and you want to check about um
this whole instagram thing is like yo
like she said you gotta be you gotta be
realistic i hear what you're saying but
you're trying to have your cake and eat
it too like it's a mouth because you
said you you've moved to a girl you
you've moved to a girl knowing how she
is knowing what she's that's the game
wait wait it's the game you've commented
you've come into the wait wait wait let
me land let me land cause i'm still in
the air this is her
um
you've come into it no one has respect
you've you've come into the game knowing
how she was in it yeah
fair enough when you come together
there's levels of compromisation but you
must also understand yeah wait you don't
do that
you want to also understand yeah
you want her to do a whole360
180 or 180
so that she can fit to your to your
standards is she going to be the same
person if you cut off all these
boundaries that you liked her for yes or
no is she going to be different because
she's not on instagram anymore is that
what you're saying yes or no yeah it's
what is she going to be different be sad
it's not a hard question no no sorry
guys is she going to be different now
that she's not on instagram
she shouldn't be
thank you very much so she's no
different than she has an instagram or
she has an instagram menus
just listen to two minutes listen
will men
on the street yes right so she's right
right so she's still available right so
why is it so hard for you to get rid of
your instagram but things are inevitable
hold on bro
why is it so hard for you to get rid of
your instagram all right the real
question go on
i just told you
that like i've had my instagram
personally since i was 12 i don't i
don't use it as like a dating platform
that's why my page is private because
it's it's my life like what i want on
there i select who's on there i select
who's on there my family's on there so
now i can't contact my family because i
don't i don't text and call my family
every day you are trying to pretend like
i'm like you don't know what i'm saying
there's a difference between there's a
difference between i sell pots and
pottery on my instagram and i didn't say
it was a [ __ ]
wait hold on let me let me land let me
land there's a difference between
selling pots and pottery on instagram
and you have your instagram page there's
a difference between you have cats that
you post on instagram and dinner on your
page there's a difference between you
using your instagram to message your
family that you might know from a broad
and okay cool there's a difference
between that and you know what i am
talking about bro you know with the
advertisement the advertising
advertising
online the advertisement of you online
okay that's what we're talking about
don't shift the goal post we're talking
about you the with the normal page where
you go in a certain gallery and be like
oh i've seen everything that's what's
happening
that's the type of girls you're going
for if you're going for it if she is she
has if she's if she hasn't got that then
she
but if you're going for the girls that's
broadcasting themselves on um or in
bathing suits and that
know what comes with girls that
broadcast themselves in bathing suits
like if you want a girl that doesn't
want that then go for a girl that
doesn't do that if she doesn't do that
you won't have a problem with her
instagram and all right and and the
point that i would lead to that is so
has most girls got instagram yeah yeah
right so most girls have got it anyway
yeah so it's not like oh you could just
on a situation of oh you know what i'm
saying you're on instagram or you're not
in on instagram we're talking about
people that are already on instagram
okay okay
i can combat that and then we're going
to do some chats after that
so you're saying that most females most
women are on instagram of course yes
speaking personally
if you if you're looking for someone
that
isn't
pro-trained that they're in the streets
my page my page does that i it
portrays that i'm not in the street
sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
my praise just portrays that i'm not for
the streets but
i ain't ugly by any means right so if
you're looking for somebody that um
that doesn't give you that feeling that
oh they're gonna have people slide into
their dm's are they going to be talking
to the next men or however it is the
reason the reason why you don't want her
on instagram if that's something that
you don't want if she
is portraying if the way that she got
you is the way she's going to get the
next man maybe you shouldn't go for that
woman yeah it sounds like you're
insecure
okay
i want to add something i don't i don't
think you're insecure i think um
one thing i will look at is
this really is dependent on the status
of the man if the man
is at a higher status in level of wealth
or in the top 15 to 20 of men you'll
find that he's going to find girls that
are more attractive these girls will
have a lot of options so then it becomes
one of those things where he'll go okay
cool
i'm gonna need you to delete your
instagram because the type of attention
you're going to create or get
is
well above the average woman when we're
talking about average p like people like
they're not gonna facilitate this much
attention where
the opportunity to cheat is so
far and varied you lot live in a fantasy
world
we're gonna do some super chat so we got
a bunch of super chats happening um so
the first one
is uh
info vader he said when women cheat the
relationship is already over in their
mind when a man cheats he's he's just
horny it does it doesn't mean
it's fair or okay a woman must show
genuine desire or men needs to move on
higher not so far super chat second one
is from
young ill
young l thomas i think that's how you
say it oh sorry
uh info vader donated 10
thank you info vader
next one young ill thomas i think i said
your name right hopefully um donated
1.99 thank you sir
um
does she have it does she have any
thoughts uh i don't know who he's
talking about
you
who me yeah
you're the most quietest one here just
like each other bitching all right we
don't want to hear you i'm letting y'all
talk i'm letting y'all talk
all right um from duck apes he donated
ten dollars
i know people really think they work
hard but they don't i also know people
who can do 30
30 minutes of work that takes someone
eight hours to do
okay
uh next one from jonathan bowling he
donated five dollars
everyone's opinions are based on their
perspective and how they are exposed to
new information most should have
opinions
that change over time that's true
that's false what
carry on with the super chats okay um
young l thomas he donated another uh
4.99 four dollars uh pearl bro
you home
your homie gonna die alone because she
refuse
refuses knowledge leave her we don't
want her to rub off on you
[Music]
he donated four pounds he's just sent a
little tea emoji yes big t uh j yeah uh
he said deleting ig is extreme
establishing a code of conduct is more
realistic
uh imo understand understand the guys
though been there and had that convo
with my girl it's long uh last one from
mike boldazar um confidence is crucial
with women
those are all the super tests thank you
all for super chats that is going
towards
equipment
okay so
we're gonna
shift it a little bit on the next
question i have
for you all
is uh
cheating different now we're not on
talking stage it's like
what whatever it is it's cheating
different for men and women yes yeah
men don't
i think men men
explore options if they have it i've
heard someone say that and
they don't actually i think
because i think once someone on the
super chat said uh
said um
when men women cheat it's just because
they're horny i think you can have sex
with another girl and love your woman
you're saying jonathan cause you won't
love that
you don't love that girl that you beat
her did it
the love making that you do to your
woman is different to
the beating that you do to any other
girl so you're saying it's considered
cheating when emotions get involved yeah
yeah
and that's and that's and that's and
that's where a woman comes into it
because women before they can even sleep
with a man they have to build that sort
of emotion in their head before they can
even sleep with a man
jonathan so so i believe men don't cheat
i think women cheat wait so just to go
out for your qu like your answer if
you're saying and i i'm not saying you
because it's
a common thing that like oh guys are
cheating because they want someone to
have sex with if you're like why don't
you just tell your partner like you know
like i agree with that i think i think
yeah i think yeah i think what's it i
think
no way i think many men i think men
should actually be honest and tell their
partners
and be like yo this is how i am in it
like but
earlier it depends on the status of the
man
decided it depends on the matter it
depends on the status of the man because
some men don't have the i was telling
this my friend the other day some men
can't afford to tell kills that they
can't afford it they literally can't
afford to lose you lose everyone lose
everything because but a certain man can
afford to tell you that and you have to
tell you what you know
you told you that i told you that oh yo
i i might step out i might step out no
but i'm not even saying that i might
step out i'm saying why don't you come
to your wait what no you hey let finish
please can i can i say my piece
my question is i'm not saying oh hey
babe i'm gonna step out i'm saying why
don't you come to your woman if the if
you're saying that you need more sex why
aren't you coming to your woman hey like
i i need to [ __ ] some more like
i can't lie to you one girl can't
satisfy my mother thank you bro you know
act like
so
that's fine if you say that and like
specifically if you're coming to a
relationship saying that like hey like i
have to be polygamous i'm not going to
lie to you like
i'm i'm going to be sleeping with other
people or whatever and that's why again
i i stated when you're beginning this
relationship you're you're both agreeing
i love you you know but you're very
competitive no i'll tell you why i'll
tell you why in the sense of this you
know what a man's like right
i i do know what men are like but thank
you i know a lot i know a lot of people
that will be just fine
haystack you're yeah to find a needle in
here
no listen because i'm asking a genuine
question so the thing is why why i ask
because if you if if this statement is i
need to have more sex why are you not
coming to your it's not more sex that i
want six yeah
explain the difference like please do
like okay so okay all right can i say
something not every okay when i'm having
intercourse with a a female
not no sex is the same okay as a man we
our sexual urges get
fulfilled when we go for variety or we
go for i want a big battery this time i
want a small but it's not necessarily
that i i'm
her connected to that is what i i'm i
want the whole no
i want to really
bust in it and i want to get to where
i'm at sometimes i would even i would
even
um i would even be where i needed to be
and be and been like why did i even go
there yeah like why did i even bother
with her like you know i'm just gonna
say i know i'm gonna get into headache
now with her over this thing just
because i went like you know i'm saying
we had a physical act and now it's very
emotional now and it's like i didn't
even want it to go emotional where i
wanted you to stay there on my level but
you're never going to be on my level
because you're not i'm not so
so i'll give you a second
so to go back what you said earlier
about understanding
men and women and how they think and how
they talk you you mentioned learning
spanish learning the language i would
say is different than understanding a
person and how they operate if you
already know that engaging sexually with
a woman is going to be emotional for the
woman
why
why
stick to why don't you
perfect why don't you just stay with the
one person but even if you want to step
out and sell your while go ahead do that
why be in a relationship with a woman
and put her through that because you
know it's emotional i'll tell you why
you think it's i'm being in a
relationship with a woman but again who
controls a relationship a man controls
relationship so if like you are out
there looking for a relationship
correct
just like many a lot of girls are
looking for a relationship a man might
say you know what you're looking for a
relationship i might use that to my
advantage like okay i see you desperate
i'm going to use that i'm not really
looking for a relationship but if you
want to hear the right words you're
going to hear the right words right
you know what i'm like as a man you know
what my intentions are i want to get to
that nookie so you if you know what my
intentions are you have to
look i'm just being sized
you need to put in like what you want
from that relationship like some girls
are like listen i'm not giving it up
unless this guy takes me gauchos or
makes me like this i'm not giving it up
like oh he has to marry me before you
give this to me or it depends on what
you put your price on in it what you're
putting the price of your
couches that's what i'm right that's
what i'm saying if you're obviously if
you're not in a relationship do whatever
you want but if you establish that
relationship with that woman and you
step out you established it no because
both you both talked about finishing
you both talked about you both
established it it was a common
conversation you said you my woman i'm
your man this that in the third
but you still stepped out
why if you both are on the same page
about you know i love you i love you my
love i love i love listen if a man tries
it i would i'll die speaking to the mic
i will i will kill for you i would work
till my back breaks for you i would give
you the best kids ever prove it
but i'm saying to you when that espanol
passes and she's looking
like i don't mean to do what i'm gonna
do but often
and you know what bro don't don't hate
me
i love you bro i just said i loved you i
love you bro like i don't like her like
i'm saying like
you're not you're not bending at your
back like how she bends her back bro
she's not
you're not dirty like how she's dirty
but i don't want a dirty girl i don't
want a dirty girl
one at a time
i'm gonna put for something i i believe
a man's nature is to want to pursue
anything he can however that only
depends if he can do that which would
depend on his status wealth or
essentially clout if he if he's able to
do that then he will do that a woman is
trying to attract the highest valuable
man she can
so at that moment you've got to
understand can every woman do that no
can every man go and pipe as many girls
as they want no no so you need to take
into consideration that although this is
what you want you may not be able to do
that
so should it be a conversation up front
yes like yeah like
like lie to us you sit down with us at
your significant other and be like let's
look at each other lie to her let's look
at each other i can get any man i want
and you can get any woman you want it
should this should not be a conversation
when you sit down they're not gonna say
for the woman to get any man she wants
but this is what i will say
so you're you're saying that you want
your woman to go for any guy oh no yes
no no no no no no no no no
i would like to think she wants me in it
no because what i'm saying and you're
going to 100 agree with what i'm saying
along the lines of polygamy you are
wanting the guy to be the one reaching
out to multiple women you don't want the
woman reaching out yes that's fine i i'm
not i'm saying you're gonna agree with
this
but the point is like it's not it's not
for the woman to step out like you're
and
a lot of a lot of women will agree to
that a lot of women will like that's why
i'm saying if you start the relationship
and say hey this is the the foundation
of our relationship a lot of people will
go for that which is why i all i keep
saying you start off and say this is how
our relationship is because if you say
it from the beginning
there's people that are going for that i
love how you said that honesty right
honestly right so why are girls not more
honest
you go you go you go
you go you go on days you go on dates
that you're not interested in the men in
there you do things that men are not
interested in and we're getting away
for honesty we want honesty we want
honesty honesty is what we want
okay women don't trap men go on honesty
that's what we want darling did you not
say that men are responsible for the
relationship so you're choosing to stay
in that if you're the one responsible
for the
relationship you're choosing to be
intertwined in that no but the thing is
yet if a girl
if a girl is stepping out
that that doesn't mean you're we're not
in a relationship then
we're not in a relationship
we're a relationship yeah obviously
because you know what we're like before
of course because what i mean but why
are you doing that
you're not giving up your instagram i'm
not giving up let my brother talk
to him
get the camera because this is this is
this is
[Laughter]
i don't even know where to start like
what what my brothers are saying yeah
that's all right can you hear me
what my brothers are saying yeah
i love all of you yeah but
you lost smoking skittles
because i i can't i can't sit here and
and kind of like accept and agree with
what you're saying i i mentor
young boys yeah they're gonna hear what
you guys are saying yeah and be like wow
like okay i guess this this is what it
is
you said something and along the lines
of first let me just say this here
a man that cannot control his sexual
desires cannot control his life okay
so
also do you mean false that's false
the point i was going to make is yeah
you know
how you are okay like if we go with
nature okay a man is the way he is if
you know that this is the way this is
the way you are yeah
and you choose to accept it
you are at fault
how can i can i say so because it's not
everything like i was born
everyone has like characteristics that
they're born with yeah
but not every characteristic is a good
characteristic definitely not every
habit is a good habit
if you know that with you you have a bad
habit it's your it's your responsibility
to change that bro i cannot i cannot sit
here and accept that okay well i'm a man
i guess hmm that means that hmm sexually
i want to explore i want to do this but
i know that i'm with someone and me
doing this is going to hurt that person
but i don't care because that's the way
i'm going to do it that does not make
sense to me
you know the way you are you know and
you know the way a woman is bro yeah
you you because i know listen i know
what i'm saying it's a bit well to
something he's been here for thousands
of years bro does not mean you have to
accept it does not mean that you have to
go go with it
you know what i mean yeah but he's been
here his premise is the front here for
it's been here for time and i'm saying
polygamy has been there for time
racism has been enough for time do we
have to sit here and say that okay this
is the way is this is the way it's
always been so that's what we're going
to do change it okay change your
behavior wait wait if you know
if you know exactly that's what i'm
coming to the state of mind yeah you
know that okay this is what i this is
this is the way i am this is what i'm
going to do and i refuse to accept it i
can't sit here i can't i can't go to my
goal and be like oh babes yeah you know
i'm a man you know you know i'm a man
huh
you know so this is this is
this is what i'm going to do
this is what i'm going to do
he's not he's not finished he's not okay
was the original question just again
it was if cheating is different from men
and women guys and girls isn't it
is it not it is don't even care it is
different
because women are more emotional yeah
they're men this thing over my point is
yeah as men we do not have to accept
that it has to be this way
so how would you want to be awake
because we've been having this
conversation
the women have been saying the same
thing right knowing that it hurts
knowing that it hurts the other side we
do not have to accept however how would
you want it to be that men also be
emotional to it as well
i think you can discipline yourself to
the point where you don't have to sleep
with everything that moves
okay okay well firstly
randomly with bare girls that move but
not every single girl first and foremost
secondly yeah that's got standards yeah
secondly
to bring it back in here i hear you
saying oh you gotta change it this this
step but this idea of of um what's it
called guys being with one woman
came along
um huh monogamy yeah yeah monogamy come
um um polygamy start was there before
monogamy came about whether you know or
not people naturally yeah from the start
guys have been going around with
different girls monogamy came in for
society and for what's called economic
benefits like capitalistic yeah
capitalism like you marry into somebody
you get uh you get a um a
a girl who's of a lower status and then
she gets married into a guy who's of
higher status due to the fact that it's
going to benefit somebody so the other
way around yeah what is or is for the
point of it benefiting
the the original party so back in the
days medieval times the original party
being men
or women
the queen's husband is not called king
but let's go medieval times yeah you
will get people from other villages or
other lands marrying into the marion
into a king yeah even though they didn't
like him or whatever whatever just for
the sake of their alliances can be built
that's the whole point of minigaming
i must say that's one of the points of
why
monogamy came about but you need to
understand polygamy is so natural
whether you believe or not i'm not
saying it's good about the effects that
has cool it can it can do a lot i don't
i don't agree with the effects i ain't
there for however you also need to
understand polygamy is one of the most
natural things that there is about
countries
but i could be single and say i sleep
with a hundred women they'll be like
okay you want to do what you want to do
bro i have dedicated my life to free
women right i've said whatever i own
will be split three ways equally for you
no he's saying hypothetically
i don't think it's wrong that's why you
need to say whatever is good for your
partner but as long as you're providing
for that family no but what my point to
you when you said that was is that girls
sometimes don't know brother lie to them
bro if you're if if she knows if you
know that she's not taking you this is
where i said this
before we carry on before we carry on
we've got a special guest in the
building sarah yeah
[Applause]
yo folks how you doing um i just want to
say on a polygamy um uh monogamy point
right um there's a book called uh called
out of eden by a man called robert p
barash right
and he states that human beings being
mammals and part of the the family of
mammals
uh polygamy is natural to uh men within
the animal world
and
even though we think of ourselves as not
animals right we are actually animals
and and in the book it states that prior
to the um western let's say eurocentric
version of what marriage was right which
is the husband and the wife and the
white picket fence
many societies around the world from
china to japan to africa to south
america had a um polygenous or
polygamous type setup so
what i think is happening right now is
that
human beings are kind of realizing that
monogamy doesn't really work and when it
comes to cheating
i think it's like a hangover of
the politicians societies that we're
already in yeah thank you thank you yeah
and that's facts i can't even lie to you
we can't even exercise our our seeds
anymore i can i can agree with what
sarah said and agree with what y'all are
saying
no but
it all it all comes down to
the initial conversation
if you if you don't
talk to a homegirl and say like oh
i like to be polygamous or i like to
i just me that's how i am as a man and
she's she doesn't agree with it then
obviously that's not the person you want
to be with but if she's like okay cool
yeah go ahead as long as you come home
to me i'm fine then that's okay but the
problem with that is as i said earlier a
lot of men can't afford that they can't
afford to well if you can't afford it
then you're okay
that's why they lie and when they lie
and they go and cheat you understand but
then what happened but then i don't want
to lose you baby and why does that
happen though cause they're trying to
have their cake and eat it too yeah i
want to get my cake i don't want to eat
it bro that's why i bought it
i want it but know what comes with i
want it i'm trying to have your cake in
here too here's my question you're you
you mentioned a lot about women trapping
men but that is entrapment in itself if
you're like oh i'm gonna set the
foundation online that is entrapment
because no because no you can't shake
your head and say no because you're
you're set it up to where something you
know damn well she wouldn't agree with
you can do i'm telling you this is fine
thank you very much she wasn't finished
she wasn't finished that finished me but
you your main thing is you're like ah
women are trapping men women are
trapping men yeah but you're
the values that you're saying isn't
entrapment itself and you're you're can
i ask you something yeah go ahead do you
do your eyebrows no i don't i don't do
does the normal girl do eyebrows yes
does the normal girl have weave in her
hair
yeah does the normal girl have her
dentures done what is normal
does the normal girl have her makeup on
does the normal girl have on some
clothes
doesn't this girl have a bbl how does
this delay
because i tell you why because she
wasn't like i'll tell you why i'll tell
you why because you're giving me a full
sense of what you are
and you want me to come 100 real and
you're not real bro you're not real if
you talk if you tell her if you tell her
from the start yeah if that's the kind
of girl you're going for i think what
she's trying to say correct me what
she's trying to say is yeah you don't
have to lie yeah if that's what you're
on say this is what i'm on go find the
women that will accept that okay
don't go in there
yeah yeah
that's what it is and i'm saying like
there are plenty of women that will you
do not have to lie about it like that's
why some things work for one person you
might like vanilla cake he likes
chocolate she likes strawberry everyone
likes cake but we like different kinds
of cakes but you're a lot you're not
allowed to lie though
you guys like she's not saying that you
you can't lie she's not saying that you
can't lie she's saying be up front you
listed all these physicals
i'm saying you don't need to lie like
there's no reason to lie just tell the
truth because there are people that are
happily like i would i would be in a
political relationship like i wouldn't
mind you would
yeah so you but no but i'm saying like i
would be with a guy that's saying no i'm
i'm not lying i'm not lying because bro
let me tell you something it's a complex
thing to get into but if the guy
let me tell you something
bro if the guy is providing for me and
i'm not needing for anything why do i
care that you're you're
what you're saying
why am i providing for you i get what
you're saying what do you mean what am i
providing for you is that what do i mean
why am i providing for you is that now a
simple question
is that not what for several episodes
that you're oh i want to be the provider
i want to be provided don't guess light
and do not change the goal post i ask
you a simple question
answer them
all right so i'll ask another question
i'll ask another question
no no no no i don't think what he said
though about the beyond that correlates
to lying about cheating
about that i'll ask another question
so if you're completely honest about who
they are when they meet you the first
time they ordered when they when they
engaged how does that correlate with
politically we weren't born with we none
of us the clothes that we have on that's
not how we look you know i'm not going
to be faithful
there you go what are you laughing now i
thought you know what we're like
you know
i know i heard you i love that the thing
is the thing is you have to go into that
relationship knowing yeah yeah okay but
sometimes i might lie to you shut up i
don't think that's fair to be with
someone and then and then switch up
midway oh yeah by the way
[Music]
we're together but i'm finna start
seeing shamari as well
we didn't we didn't agree now he's
saying you're seeing her me her we
didn't agree today
in the beginning we said oh yeah we're
you know right right now
no it's never going to work bro she
needs to be brought along on the right
he's a really nice one 400 miles
straight away you gotta go ten twenty
feet nice like
one at a time one at a time seriously
guys
i'm not saying that okay we're gonna
start a relationship but if you say hey
like somewhere along the lines like i
think we we should add another person
and by we it's like i should have
another person that's fine but you have
to acknowledge that don't just pretend
you're gonna you want a
completely monogamous relationship and
at no point like when you know you
you're saying damn well you don't want a
monogamous relationship so why would you
go into a relationship pretending that
you want um not no is that also
that question no because why why are you
going into something pretending when you
can be real and say this is not my
intention i'll tell you why i'll tell
you why one mainly because you half the
time don't know what you want yeah
secondly
girls are very persuasive after they've
come to see the understanding of where
you are you don't want to say they want
to see in the flesh okay i don't
necessarily
sometimes i'll tell the girl listen yo
i'm a doctor you know
by week two she don't care about doctor
like she knows like that was just to
stop her in the moment like she got
captured she got she got my rasmus i'm
not saying i'm lying to no way i'm not
saying i'm lying to her but i'm like i'm
chasing them it's like babes you're the
most beautiful girl in the world i'm
lying to you you're not the world all
right i'm lying to you you're not
perspective
you want to hear truth in it all right
you're average you're all right like
what i'm trying to say you your back is
all right like you look all right can i
can i can i take you for some
viscous innit can i go inside can i can
i chill with you and i'll have other
women multiple women with you is that
all right you're saying there's nothing
but you're saying all of that and hoping
there's no problem if you want to be a
realistic and avoid problem you gotta do
what she says i can't do that what's
that which is what which is a dress from
the beach yeah you've got to say it from
the top
you gotta say
let's pause since this is a thing
because if you're saying that most men
want to be polygamous fine would you
would either one of you go say if you're
starting a relationship and and they say
at some point along the lines i want to
turn this monogamy into a polygamous
relationship would you go for that if
they're saying from the beginning would
you no would you have a polygamous
relationship anyway i have you have oh
kirsty hello have you
no i would you no
so if i was so if i was to come and tell
you listen jess hey i like you a lot but
i want to have something on the side
like you can go have them things on
exactly so i'm like you know what i
really like everything i really like no
wait hold on i really like jess i really
like her i want to love her i want to
marry her but i want something on the
side but i can't tell just listen
i want to sit on the side until
so earlier you had given
physical description but you already
know you already know that
women are going to come
the women that you want are going to
come at you all made up and done up so
you already know that you already can
see that they are
not
who they are supposed to be we we
we can't know what you're thinking you
know what i think
now all the time we don't know that
you're thinking oh i want a thing on the
side or i i'm just going to be with her
that's why we're saying
up front
of you so i'll say this like this if i
see you on instagram
doing certain things i'm not the type to
tell you turn take off your instagram
i'm the type to be like oh is that what
she's doing i'm not gonna take this guy
seriously like oh it's what what every
time i'm chilling with her what twenty
men ringing that phone and she's on yeah
i'm not taking her seriously i'll be uh
wait so i'll have fun with her what does
what does that have to do with
what i just said i was saying that i'm
saying to you
when it comes to honesty
sometimes some people
honesty is the good thing to be with and
sometimes in hindsight when people hear
the word let's be honest they think yeah
that's the best thing to do but when
they're in the situation it's not the
best thing to do
at that point and we're being and i'm
and i'm being honest by saying you're
not like you actually are however thank
you bro you actually are however yeah
till your point if you want to be honest
is that just a certain point yeah yeah
the thing is when you're going in that
and you go and lying i'm not even saying
you can do that but know what the end
game is no the consequences of what's
gonna happen don't assume you can go
into the game lion and think it's gonna
come out like honest results you can't
that's like easy you planting a
strawberry seed and one in melons like
every girl you went to you had the same
game for huh huh no say that again every
girl you've went for was the same game
that you used to go for them what do you
mean by that i keep it buckled away
i say that personally because of
personal experience in um
um just growing up in it i'm not going
to dive too deep into it however
personal experience in it yeah i know
long end game the head they can't worth
it g so you have a main chapter up line
right well
every girl i use the same kind of game
i'm coming on the same approach hi my
name is so and so i'm this kind of guy
i'm very straightforward i'm going to be
this way
listen i don't say all of that stuff but
you know
or
would you adapt to the certain girl that
you're moving to
know if you go for the same type of girl
would you adapt to the girl if you're
the same girl then you still adapt
because you're adapting because she's
the same girl but i'm saying if she
changed would you adapt i hear what
you're saying in it yeah you're not no
that's not an answer here what i'm
saying sorry no question i'm answering
your question
i can only say to the minus extent i
adapt by adapt do no no hear this the
adaptation yeah
it's only parts when you're coming in
with somebody and you're compromising
you're not going to say the same when
you compromise or get with someone
you're not 100 the way you are when
you're single yes right right right then
so do you over the main part for the
main part i am myself i i don't change
people are a certain way when they first
get into relationship and they change to
what they naturally like bro you're on
your best behavior when at the start of
relationships not my best behavior it's
part of me lying about who i am bro let
me know what you think i'm not sure is
your best trait bro
your best one best straight ever a man's
best straight is his lies bro this man
take it take it
out i want to say that i don't mean like
lies like yo listen oh you're like weird
out there i'm talking about fabrication
um
elaboration the truth
listen
listen i am i am not good
i'm
know the results of lying is what's
going to cause the results
headache bro are you single huh yeah
thank you very much so
yes so me lying me lying me lying and
him telling the truth none of it works
because there's a process to things not
everything's gonna work out straight
away whether you be honest that person
that you could have been with could have
been not to your not to standards but it
just doesn't correlate in the long run
so now you've got to break off you don't
know why i've um why things are broken
off right it couldn't have been from
lion could have been from something else
you're not coming
thank you external internal there's
variables however if you're coming in
with lying no you're going to get lying
intention
you're going to get lying results simple
so you've never lied huh no who said
that no one ever said that wait wait
wait wait i want to hit i want to hear
where his brain's at have you ever lied
no no no no you see what do you mean of
course then so he's never lied
everyone has lied like that's what i
thought
in what sense in what sense of life and
what sense of life there's no sense like
you they're speaking to them
what's the sense
i'm not saying that you have to have bad
intentions but i don't think everyone in
their whole entire life have been 100
honest like and that's just the truth
how you're saying oh sweet little lie or
like it's it's just a bit from the truth
either way like at the end of the day
rather it doesn't have to be cute like
honesty is not always cute like it can
be tough and the thing is
of me saying that that you've lied it's
not a thing against you i ever no one
tells the truth hundred percent of the
time but that's why i ask in what sense
so there's no sense there's no sense
it's either a lie or a truth that's what
i'm saying no but when i say in what
sense now i heard that point but we're
not saying what's saying how far huh
yeah how like what sort of lies are we
she just said everyone's allowed to lie
and you just came back and said okay
lying to a certain extent
listen this man is you're saying oh
we're putting words in your mouth i
never said that i didn't say it's okay
to lie i said at some point everyone has
lied there's no man that tells 100 like
that tells the truth 100 of the time it
doesn't mean you can't try to tell the
truth all the time it means that at some
point you've fallen short so why so why
are you lying
i just think i just think girls can't
happen we're humans we're humans like
there's no way okay so i just i i why do
you lie
oh okay i have talalah i didn't say i
didn't lie
why do you lie the same way so many
people do it's escape it's right it's a
it's an escape out listen i didn't say i
didn't lie obviously that's why i said
we can't tell the truth 100 of the time
you can do your best to to be your best
the best version of yourself that
you will fall short of that at some
point at one point another you'll fall
short of that rather oh i just i just
put a dent in your car oh i'm not gonna
leave hey my number speaking of my i'm
not my number is 0.678 i'm in a rush but
here's my here's my number chat me later
so we can like fix whatever the
insurance
i didn't tell the truth because i could
have fessed up some people would do that
though i i didn't say that people won't
i said i know can we stick to the topic
but i'm saying to you you're willing to
lie about something as small as a card
then you're not
i do have a question for everybody so
if you are in a relationship and
either you are you'll say your
significant other so the woman or the
man is making
a substantial amount of money taking
care of you you ain't gotta worry about
nothing
would you be okay
if they stepped out and would you still
be in that relationship so if if you're
if you're not the breadwinner if the
person that you're with is a breadwinner
and they have a substantial amount of
money and they're taking care of you and
you're just chilling and they step out
would you still be in that relationship
with them first of all i think that's
first of all i think that's unrealistic
for men because i don't think women are
women are providing for men yes they
might be a substantial minority
there might be
more guys
come on
when you weigh it up for real you get me
for real in general there might be a
substantial minority i don't disagree
with it you understand but for you
personally for you for me
i don't think i don't think i don't even
think i could realistically be in that
situation to be honest but look but if i
was if she was providing for me
i would already have assumed that she
might step out because she's providing
for me do you understand and girls our
girls are really hypocritical like that
happening is real she understands so if
she's with a guy that's not doing
anything he's in the yard all the time
she'll tell her girls yeah he's always
in the house he's when he ain't doing
nothing he ain't getting up to anything
oh i'm here
doing my lawyer stuff or whatever blah
blah and he's not doing nothing well
she will step out with a lawyer or a
barrister or whatever she would step out
would you be okay with that of course
not i would i would i would leave
but he's saying he wouldn't never be in
that position
i couldn't put myself in that position
because i would already assume that yo
i'm a guy i don't know how females are
they're hypocrites so it's like i'm why
am i gonna put myself in a situation
where i'm not providing for her i would
rather provide for you can i ask you
something after that obviously i can't
lie same one bargain if if a girls will
provide and they will tv plan she's
allowed
oh that's a whole man situation in
itself but to play devil's advocate
let's say um you've met the thing in the
lab before you don't even know her her
status in it until you like but um
you you're chatting a chapter and after
you are now doing the thing so you don't
know what it's like until you've gotten
a bit deeper in with her and now i don't
know whatever emotions or whatever
the relation that the dynamic is would
you still stay with her knowing that now
you've known because your your time's in
yeah would you still stay with him no
bro oh yes you're stepping out i'm gone
yeah i'm gone bro like think what's it
like obviously if she's if she's got
money if she's got money and she wants
to look after me and i'm doing my thing
and she's calm she's calm with it as you
said there's some women that are calm
with it and i don't disagree with it are
you gone or is she gone like
most likely she'll be gone because i
think what's it like wait hold on
because i want you to answer this most
girls before they leave a relationship
they've already decided they've left
everything yeah yeah yeah relationship
yeah right so yeah
do you agree with that it's true so you
see you're checking out so you're lying
then because you're staying in a
relationship
all right on that we have wait wait wait
we're going to make some substitution
we're going to get sara in as
well yeah
[Music]
all right but we have some super chats
um let's go see picture
i'm not quite sure how to um
how to say this person's name but they
donated 20 pounds
um and they just said wrap it up they
just said uh big ups each other evening
to you all so you're just saying what's
up to everybody
all right the next one
there we go sentience
um they donated twenty dollars it says
it seems unorganized this is a podcast
not a pub
where
where you're trying to overtalk each
other increasing as one increasing as
the more pissed and louder you get
staying on point gives a good flow for
the audience to follow get them just
i'm trying
all right last one up north society they
donated three dollars it's a one one at
one at a time guys so just remember one
at a time when we're talking just let
everybody get their thoughts out and
then you can get your thoughts out so i
know it could be jarring listening to it
with lots of voices
so um continuing on with that question
ladies i want to hear your your thoughts
about it if a man's providing for you
paying the bills taking care of you and
he steps out would you stay in the
relationship or would you
leave the relationship
i i wouldn't stay in the relationship
because from my perspective my emotional
needs would be disturbed too much and i
think my own mental health would
definitely be compromised because for me
me personally a relationship's about
trust and when i enter into any
relationship whether or not it'd be a
friendship or a romantic relationship
there has to be trust and once that
trust has broken then
i'd mentally find that very difficult to
be around that person because i'd always
be second guessing myself and what
they're doing so i personally couldn't
do it because i also wouldn't want to
impact on them and because i know i'd be
a certain way and i'd probably be
you know more
i'd i'd not be happy and that would
impact their happiness so i wouldn't
stay in the relationship
so would you just leave or would you
like
demand certain
like respects be upheld in a
relationship
i think it depends i've been cheated on
in the past and i tried to work it out
with the individual i was very young at
the time but it didn't work out and
i held this
resentment towards him and so he became
very unhappy he wanted to stay with me
but he also lied throughout the whole
process about the whole thing
um he he wouldn't and it was going back
to he didn't want to lose me
um but what it did was it really
affected my mental health and confused
you yeah for a very long time and it and
i'm not gonna lie affected future
relationships after that i'm over it now
it was a very traumatic time i mean
would you would you like thinking like
going back right now would you go back
into the relationship now knowing that
like was he good enough to like stay in
the relationship even though he
you know i mean because sometimes it's
like girls would leave the relationship
because he's cheating even though the
relationship is 10 10 it's like
everything's going right but he just
stepped out like it's like would you are
you just going to leave that like it
wasn't a good relationship if i'm honest
we were both super young and it was very
toxic and and we were both very toxic
for each other i was toxic he was toxic
and i hope that i definitely learned
from that relationship and i hope that
he did too
um it it was very sad the way everything
ended but i just think if you know it's
going to affect both your mental health
just don't just don't be in it if you
can't handle it and you know further
down the line you're constantly going to
be bringing things up just just don't do
it because
fundamentally happiness over everything
right and if you can't be happy don't be
together it might hurt in the first
instance to like separate but it will be
better in the long run for both of you
i mean what what causes girls to be in a
relationship right now then because i
find a lot of girls are single right now
and
the problem for most girls is like i
don't trust guys i don't trust but you
know what we're like like i mean like
okay it's because
all women
are dating the same guy
so there's no like the dating pool for
men is this big and then
we have all these requirements they got
to be this tall look like this make this
much money so it makes a pool smaller
and smaller smaller so women are dating
the same guy from that pool because
more women want this type of guy this
high value guy than they do this one
over here and so
once this woman dates it oh that man's
trash the next that man's trash because
it's just the same type of men i i get
you yeah but if all women are chasing
the same guy that guy should be in
demand why why then should he change for
you like like i don't do you know like a
man is not gonna like a woman's not
gonna really necessarily she doesn't
want to change for a man he should he
should accept her for who she is but the
woman is not accepting him for who he is
you know he's a ten percent man you know
bear gala on him you know he he could
get if he wants you know he could
exercise his options you know he's got
money on him you know he could go away
you know he's talking in the thing you
know he's got bear gal so why are you
trying to change him and then at the
same time you're trying to change him
you don't want to change yourself and
but the thing is on the flip side of
that is like as a matter of fact that's
what actually attracted you to the guy
yeah you were attracted to that guy
because he was the guy that all the
girls wanted everybody knows they've
been school where they've been college
there's a certain type of guy in college
and school that got all the girls but i
get that but what my point
hold on
i need to say this i need to say this
no you say oh yeah but listen
no no no because you want you want your
point to be heard no you're not you're
not you're not you're not getting
um if women
understand that they're going for the
same types of guys right they know that
they're going to get the same types of
results which is one of the reasons why
a lot of women fight over men they don't
fight over
the other
fifty percent of men they're fighting
over that top ten percent which is why
women always get themselves into fights
over men they're fighting over the men
that album other women
so the thing is is that
it's a catch-22 because
they want this type of guy but they
don't
understand what it takes to be with that
type of guy and that type of guy like
you said he's got a lot of options right
he's got a lot of
options and women need to kind of
understand that that's part and parcel
of being with that type of guy but they
want to make that guy
exclusive to them mm-hmm they think that
they can change they think that they can
they think that that's the one potential
to them
it's not going to work so like i've said
before on this podcast yeah there is at
least a 40 to 50 of men
that women are totally missing the
average dude i would put you in there
say again i would put you in that top
percent man based of what um
yeah i just say that i am who i am but
i'm saying there's a there's a 50 of men
that women are just they walk past them
on the street they don't want their
attention they don't even want to hear
from these types of guys those are the
types of guys that i will actually marry
you come on that top 10 of guy yeah
marrying you because he's got too many
options why are you single
why am i single yeah i was in a 10-year
relationship bro you're you're one of
you just came out of it i'm not i'm just
i'm i'm chilling
question for you then
why why are you single
silent
no there's not silence at all i know 100
why i'm single girl right now if i go
through my instagram i've got about 10
girl i could be girls right now
girlfriends sorry 100 exclusive if i
wanted to be exclusive but right now i'm
enjoying my freedom and i'm enjoying
multiple how long have you enjoyed your
comments what multiple women how long
have you been enjoying your freedom
i'm 35. i mean i've been enjoying too
long bro
[Applause]
can i tell you the trouble with that
though
you say you're
you're in your field yeah
i'm in my prime i'm enjoying myself yeah
having the lit career
yes get me i mean the prem all right
good for you the problem the problem
number comes here when you would when
you would
you're going to meet someone you're
going to meet a woman yeah he's going to
strike you and you're going to be like
okay i want to come out of that now yeah
come into the field yeah
you have you have
baggage
30 35 years plus of baggage of you being
out there in the field when it's not
going to be time for you to come in the
barn yeah you'll have so many problems
yeah because you have built habits
you've built characteristics within
within yourself that when you're gonna
want to have that serious relationship
you won't be able to what serious
relationship i never said i wanted a
rich serious relationship okay if you
don't want to be in terms of one serious
relationship i want multiple serious
relationships that's you
that's you that's true that's you i'm
trying to i'm trying i'm trying to
that's you that's fair
it's your life let me just let me finish
let me finish it's your life
you can do you can do what you want yeah
my my trouble is here i have
again
i meant to a lot of young men and they
feel like they can do this thing yeah
where
they will be out playing on the field
yeah for so long
and then
knowing that they would want to be in
that city if you don't want to be in a
serious relationship that's fine great
but multiple what what multiple streets
he wants to be polygamy
all right that's on you i'm trying to
say that on the person that wants to be
with with one person yeah don't want to
be monogamous i want to be with one
person yeah when it's going to be time
for you yeah to do that you won't be
able to bro because you've built so many
habits so many bad characteristics yeah
you're gonna end up hurting the woman
that's what i'm trying to say to you
practice that from now don't wait until
you're 40 35
70 and then say all right i'm ready
because you won't be able to do it but
if you don't do it if that's
yeah that's cool but are you currently
building bad habits right now
no i'm actually trying to get rid of bad
habits that's what i'm saying what i'm
saying why are you celibate or something
have you never had sex before marriage
i'm a virgin you're a vet
it's a lie
why is it lie again again again thank
you thank you for being here
do you know where it is you know
it means he has no contribution in terms
of how i see my si because i work with
women bro
hold on there's a difference between
chilling with women yeah and sleeping
with women they have completely
different relationship to you yeah bro
completely different trust you're
allowed to get away with certain so much
different stuff when you sleep with them
as opposed to being friends with them
there's a barrier that you have to keep
yeah and i'm saying to you in terms of
multiple women i want to look after
multiple women i don't want to just
cheat with multiple i want to look after
have kids with multiple women i want to
have a broad family i want to i want all
of them to be fine i want them to be
perfect it's not just
i'm just sleeping around no bro there's
a maximum to matter so so question
though you're a virgin are you waiting
on marriage or something too i am yeah
you're waiting on marriage so it's a
christian thing it's not even a
christian thing it's it's a personal
decision i rate that that i've made
since i was young that i'm gonna wait
three years until until i'm married
right now so um would you now prefer
like
your partner to be a virgin also
no why what
it doesn't matter to me
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter to
me whether she is or not it doesn't
matter to me
the more bodies a girl has so the more
people she's being with yeah it's the
hardest part it's harder for her to pay
a bond and be with you long term yeah so
if you're saving yourself for the wife
you bet you better want a girl that's a
very ideally yeah ideally yeah but i
know the realities of this world in this
society
you won't really find that yeah but you
wouldn't find a man that's 25 black in
london chilling as a virgin bro it's
normal your acting is wrong but an
anomaly as well it's rare so look for
your anomaly don't say okay i'm gonna
sacrifice you wait wait wait wait look
for your anomaly that's why i'm single
right and um i was actually watching a
video today as a matter of fact on ken
kendra g yeah kenji g had a woman on her
show he was 38
and a virgin
right and she was saying that she's been
looking for a man
and she wants a man of god and she was a
christian thing right so i'm like all
right cool respect it but she's 38
and she's never had sex and she's not
she hasn't been in a serious
relationship have you been in a serious
relationship i haven't seen his
relationship yeah you're in one now no i
have been in one i'm not in one now but
i have been in one so when the serious
relationship start started sorry um
how come it didn't lead to the place
where
because i told the person i was from the
beginning this is this is what i'm on
this is what i'm doing and i'm not i'm
talking as if it's
it's like easy it's like yeah the the
thoughts don't come up or
the the
the the the temptation is not there
that's not what i'm saying of course how
tall are
you six free why okay i just want to put
that out there for the ladies out there
my point is here it's not like it's not
like it's the temptations are not there
but we're all human yeah we're all human
so the temptation is there but
that's what i was that's what i'm saying
to you about about intentions and why
you do things i already know what i'm
doing while i'm doing what i'm doing i
already know like this is what i this is
what i want to be ideally i want to find
someone who's also on the same page as
me compatibility i think it says there's
something that i admire in that but
there's also something that's a little
bit naive in that tell me for me right
um because you're living in a world yeah
where you get eaten up
like you will get eaten alive man like
by women women out here will see listen
women out here will see them oh my god
it's innocent oh my god and they will
come into your life bro and they will
eat you a lot of women out here a lot of
the women out here
in these days and times bro
we have a very very special uh super
chat from um the v host she says stop
waffling these hoes
stop walking
what you're saying you're mad
bro listen i would love bro
because if you actually
think since i've been here since i've
got it if you actually calculate
everything i've seen i've been saying
yeah it it it portrays the man that i am
yeah so everything that i've said yeah
it it goes it contributes to the man
that i am so me saying this now
shouldn't be shocking because if you
actually reflect back to what i've said
you can see that it matches what i'm
saying but i agree with that i agree you
are you are keeping it on the same level
i'm not going to say you're not keeping
on the same level but
we have to be truthful with the girls
bro because
like the way i see it yeah the way i see
it here the society that we live in lies
the girls every single day they lie to
the girls like if you lie women by
justin so they lie to the girls every
single day so i think if we're going to
have these conversations we have to keep
it real with the gallup stick to
yourself
who's to say that your truth what you're
saying
you you want to be with you both want to
be multiple women like
like
there's a separation between me okay
okay i'll say you you both are okay with
stepping out that's your truth no i'm
not okay with stepping out you're you're
okay with what you said earlier the
polygamy that's the best way to put it
you're okay with plaguing me
he's saying that he is not that's your
truth that's his truth how is
what you're what he's saying lying how
it triggers
yeah yeah do you know my bro yeah
um
you see
when you understand women yeah women
generally and i was i was talking on the
show about it i was on the show talking
about it the other day um
you know women want a man with sexual
experience generally they want a man who
is experienced
sexually
um
because when it comes to sex women want
to be satisfied sexually um and like i
said a man can have sex with a hole in
the wall and be satisfied
he doesn't even know who's on the other
side he's fine do you get what i'm
saying but when it comes to women having
sex right um they want to be they want
to know they want to be satisfied and
that actually asks i think i was on the
show with you jeff and we were saying
would you want a man who's a virgin and
just and i really believe you were like
no
people quiet now you see i'm trying to
say that i didn't want to say that
you're too hot but what i'm watching
what i'm trying to say is like this
world yeah the reason why the most
powerful men have got women yeah is
because they've shown that they can get
women
so what i'm saying to you kudos to them
so what i'm trying to say is
women when you understand the psychology
of women women generally want a man who
knows what he's doing when it comes to
sex so
i'm not trying to disrespect you in any
way shape or form but what i'm saying is
in this world that we're living in right
now you might be hard-pressed
to find a woman who's cool with a man
who has no sexual experience no i don't
think i'll be hard-pressed um
i think if he was living in 1950
you probably would have been perfect
not even that far
by night and just to say just to say to
to any brothers that
are anomaly like me um we're very
different so
um don't don't let that change who you
are as a person or what not um what my
brother's saying here yeah
um it does not mean that um
because you're a virgin you won't be
good at sex you know um it does not mean
that at all where you getting practice
from uh that's what
can i say
listen the premise is set up i'll
actually put something forward and i
don't know if this is fully correct but
my belief is if you're a virgin as a guy
right i do agree with your point um
women generally want a man with
experience however if you're a virgin as
a guy it's probably best that you go for
a girl that's a virgin because what you
don't want is to find a girl that's
experienced
been experienced by a guy that is very
experienced and you won't be she's
looking at you like what the hell is
essentially you won't be able to live up
to the expectations
it's the same when it comes to uh
corn you may see something on the screen
and
yep there we go yeah there you go
i was like
what you may see something you may see
something that someone does on the
screen and you like oh yeah i'm gonna
try that or i want my girl to do that
and
it happens and you're like it's not it's
not like that didn't give me the same
feeling so you go back to that to get
that feeling it's the same it's the same
way how he was talking about how you
want if you have somebody that is
experienced and they have that main one
when they are with you and you're not as
experienced or
you're not hitting it right they're
going to be thinking about that person
or that incident to make it through can
i interject here i i don't want people
to be
afraid of doing what my management yeah
yeah
yeah that's something good that there's
something honorable
that you're supposed to do if i could
where my contention comes in is your
advice to men
to men that's already experiencing that
that feel like like i'm not going to go
to a guy that's an expert in in
motorcycles about cars bro like what i'm
trying to say i'm going to go to the guy
that knows how to run the cars and be
like okay
i'm not to do that i could hear you i
understand with the motorbikes like i
understand the breeze in your air and
you know i'm saying understand whoa whoa
but sometimes i want to just get the
down in the nitty gritty of someone
that's been there in the field like i
say when i'm coming i'm coming from the
field bro i'm telling you from
experience bro i know what women like
bro i when i first started i thought
women were on the pedestal bro like
you're supposed to admire them they they
can't do no wrong they're perfect and
they're perfect in their own way i'm
trying to say and then i have to be like
wait hold they're humans bro
they're humans just like you they have
needs just like you'd have once just
like you they have experiences just like
you they have stuff that they want to
achieve just like you
i'm just saying to this i understand
what you want to achieve i understand
where you want to go in life but if you
want to be with this person at this
point in your life there are certain
things that come with it yeah there's
certain things that you have to be with
there's certain rules that you have to
regulate you have to keep in line
not because i want to control you but
because i have experienced from past and
know that bro that only leads to this
bro i don't want to have to be going to
you two weeks from now bro like what's
this bread doing putting hot faces and
things like that that's another argument
for us bro that didn't need to be there
bro because at the end of the day you
don't know you're not going to answer
him you don't even you don't even know
who he is but he's pissing me off bro
because he but i wouldn't do that if i
was your man oh but i'll take you here
look pictures hit you know what other
men are like bro because you would do
that yourself but no not you but
you do that
like that there's like bro like he's not
doing it how i'm doing it kind of thing
like and i mean it's a banner that men
do but some girls do fall for that or
girls fall for that at a certain time
from us the right man
like that that true the way that drake
trolled that guy's wife 100 100 million
percent bro like if it's drake holler if
i was holding her she back that's the
dm's if there's a certain guy that she's
interested in now it becomes a problem
because now she's sitting down being
like
i like him
you ain't doing what he's doing
if i wanted to i could leave you and go
to him so you better fix up and it's
like wait hold on hold on a minute i
work 40 hours a week i provide for you i
might not be like rich and taking no no
no no but i'm doing so so so so and so
and so bro as certain men certain men do
certain things that other men can't live
up to bro
i i have a question for you hit me do
you want a polyamorous relationship and
a few wives yes
so is it will it be okay for your wives
to also absolutely not
trust that's
do you want men do you multiple men
do i want more yeah if you're with me
and i'm looking after you do you want
multiple men i wouldn't be with a man in
a polyamorous relationship exactly
because you don't want multiple men i'm
saying to you i want multiple women
because that's the thing that the point
of meeting someone's needs and knowing
that you you're not going for that so
like you wouldn't want to be in that so
you're not going for that but you would
be fine with it it's not the same
because there's things that my woman
could do that i can't do that i'll just
be like back to you just be just waiting
for the difference many men
many men it's it's acceptable for them
to be polygamous but not for the woman
and that's just something like you don't
have to understand it
but it's just how it is so it's not
shocking that he's saying
yes like i'm i'm gonna be pulling a miss
and and the wife is like agreeing to be
in that polygamous relationship
it's not going to work i just believe
that women i just believe i mean
i mean okay i'm the man you're the woman
we're in a polygamous relationship
you've got a next man
i've got to wait until your man's come
what on tuesday until like what so what
he did he does the tuesday thing and i
do the wednesday thing are you ready for
the wednesday thing after you've had the
choose dating and then
when you're pregnant
i didn't believe it
i believe women can't love two people at
the same time
they can't bro speaking to them
like women can't love two guys at the
same time you can't love this guy you
love him he like he provides for you
protects you brother and then at the
same time you love this guy as well
because i can't you can't you're like i
think of course but but i'm saying men
can love to like multiple women at like
probably
i think that it's
women they can they can love
multiple men but it's different types of
love and you're not gonna have the same
love you have for this guy over here
that you have for this guy he could be
doing stuff for you that this guy's not
doing and this guy could be doing stuff
for you that this guy over here isn't
doing so you love them for different
reasons i think that they can
i personally don't think that women can
be in multiple relationships because
that is emotionally draining for women
to have to be emotionally connected this
person mostly connect to that person in
over a friendship obviously people can
do it in friendship but when it comes
romantically
i think we're built for just one person
and that's why well not all women
because
there's some women who
can do it do you have male friends
i do have male friends do you have any
male friends that you're sexually
attracted to
huh
do you have any male friends that you
are sexually as you said female friends
have you got any male friends that you
are sexually attracted to not sexually
exactly bro that's my point bro girls
put men that they're not attracted to in
the friend zone bro
no you can be you can be attracted to
them but not sexually attracted
i understand that there's a difference
between okay like she's nice like but i
won't sleep no i'm talking about you're
sexually attracted to you it's not
really necessary for a woman to have a
man that she's sexually attracted to in
the friend zone otherwise he wouldn't
necessarily yeah but he's dependent but
he would be sexually attracted to her
though 100
you have a relationship with a girl and
she's got bear friends that are sexually
attracted to her no that's why i said
the last show was can men and women be
talking about can men and women be
friends you know what i'm saying and i'm
like
women don't have
generally okay i'm sure there are
exceptions to the rule but women don't
have
male friends and i said if you think you
got a male friend call him up at
midnight yeah tell him to come over and
have a little drink and then put it on
him and see what he does yeah because
nine times out of ten he's gonna be like
oh okay all right cool and but if he
says
no
that's your friend but can i ask you
something here why is it okay for men to
sleep with women that they're not
necessarily
feeling sexually attractively but women
they have that kind of thing where
listen i have the barrier of
i'm not really like i could give it i
can give it to you and it'll probably be
good but i'm not going to do it because
like the coochie's what you want because
a woman knows that because it's not just
about it's not just about knowing what
we have it's there's an emotional
connection that comes with when we have
sex with somebody it's not just like oh
i'ma get my rock my socks off whatever
get it boom bam boom it's something that
we release physically that is just
innate in us the i forgot what the uh
but some women can do that now woman
some women are some women with it that's
why she loses
one at a time one time i think that
that's a lie like um
that women
like i i do know that women are just
having sex with everyone but i think
they're just lying to themselves like
that they're not attracted or like have
any kind of bond with whoever they're
having sex with i think that's damn well
a lot
no i know people personally who are like
i just needed a itch to be scratched and
they just do that i feel like that's a
lie like i know some people that are
like
so as a woman if you have that sexual
urge there's not there's no one you can
go to but i just want that itch to be
scratched you have to have an emotional
bond with them
if i'm having sex with someone i have
some sort of bond with them like i no
that's not what you're asking he's
asking if you i'm saying if you're if
you're if you're in your house and
you're thinking oh i feel kind of you
know
i get what you're saying but i'm saying
i wouldn't just have sex with someone
because it's like oh like i would have
to have some sort of like
attraction for them for me you'd have to
be a friend or something but i'm saying
an emotional bond like can you can you
as a woman like have sex with a man and
have no emotional bond with him i don't
think that's possible that's what i'm
saying right so if you know that then
why why when i cheat it's the same as
you cheating i didn't say i cheated no
no no in general
if you know that you're not if you know
that it's impossible for you to be to be
emotionally disconnected from someone
and you know men is capable of doing it
why do you think that it should be the
same for men and women if you know that
we're going to be different how we react
to it
i i think
the the point is about honesty and say
how you're saying about trump
not i i understand you darling i get the
honesty part i get the trust being
broken i'm saying the principle of it
because like i said there's people that
will go for whatever you're on so you
don't have to you don't have to like put
up this facade like you can just be real
and say xyz do you know what yeah when
you tell the truth you get what you want
yeah that's what it does it actually
might take longer
it might take longer because
that's what i've come to realize like
and that's something that i've learned
in my age like
it might take longer for you to get what
you want but the more you tell the truth
about yourself the more you do people
start gravitating towards you and you
will be surprised as to how many women
like you said are actually down for a
polygamous relationship
i bet you if you start telling women up
front
i want to be polyamorous you'll find the
women that you want and they'll come
back
i do and i do have a lot of women that i
do and i'm saying i could be devil's
advocate and say i lie and i'm
explaining to you why men lie i'm
perfectly because you know honestly i
don't think i'm the best man in the
world bro but i think if she's average
bro i'm getting there bro
that's it and if i don't get her it's
her loss bro and it's like brav i'm
you might you might think i'm bit like i
have to have this kind of attitude if i
know otherwise i ain't gonna get it bro
like i have to have it
if i don't if i haven't got this
attitude i'm not gonna get her so i got
this attitude and she likes it and
she's feeding off it and it's like
i like this and i'm not coming on this
oh i need to take the gaucho no listen
y'all i'm letting you know it is boom
boom boom you know man i bear gal i'm
saying man from caribbean and that and
i'm trying to say you know how you swing
it no i'm noticing it do you know what's
funny
i'm not gonna do it in your face because
the attitude that you have here a lot of
women will be like this guy i can't take
this guy but there's a lot of they love
it i love it
my instagram says last time
like yo you sure you like that like you
couldn't you know
bro i'm not into no [ __ ]
relationships this is what this is where
the problem comes in because they'll
know they'll love that kind of guy and
then they'll want to change him for
themselves but then when they if that
kind of the thing is when you're a man
if you're a man if you're a man and you
change and you fold into that bro
she starts despising you sam but i don't
want it to change i'm just saying if you
want me to change you've got to do some
changes
all right no no you if you delete your
instagram i'm not going to chat to bear
gap i'm not going to chirps bro because
i'm in a relationship with you i'm going
to be 100
for you bro i'm i'm going to stop
chirping wait wait wait
that's a lot for two other people dad
that's a lot bro
because you just said you're going to be
100 for her but you know that you want a
polyamorous relationship so how can you
be a hundred percent because i could be
a hundred percent twice 300 percent of
course i can
and it's club
it's 100 it's a rule yeah that you get a
hundred percent islam you can have
multiple wives i'm not going to hit
united time one at a time so at this
time it's a rule in it like you have to
treat your wives equally do you
understand that's why i'm saying that's
why i i me saying in the real world
that's not practical though it's not
practical it doesn't work but i mean if
you know the premise
because you know like when you have a
parent yeah everyone
maybe people here got siblings right
they know that they weren't treated the
same as one other sibling but as a
parent you gotta treat all your children
the same yeah are you gonna give one
child one apple and give the next one
half an apple or you know or even though
you're my favorite child i'm gonna give
you like all one apple no no yeah you'll
get one apple but i'm just saying i'm
just saying the treatment like everyone
knows that depending on where you felt
in the sibling line obviously
even with have you guys ever seen sister
wives yeah okay even that the first one
is always going to be the main one
you're always gonna have that one black
mama's the first one
no i think you're just saying this to be
nice and that's why when i said that i
would do it it is circumstantial because
it would be how like it would be
something that would be built i don't
think i would just like
start my relationship like oh i want to
be in a polygamous relationship i would
be open to it like depending on because
obviously if you're saying oh i'm going
to cheat anyway
i'm going to cheat you know the upper
gallery pause pause pause like you're
you're saying you wouldn't want to be
with one girl so if i'm knowing
then that's me adjusting but i have to
know that like you have to let me
know that i agree with that and so i'll
give you that sorry and me saying that i
would be fine in a polygamous
relationship i i would want to like i
would
because i'm agreeing to this i know that
you're going to take care of me so like
i there's going to be nothing that i'm
lacking of like you know you're doing
you're hitting all the spots for me like
you're doing everything that you need to
do as my man are you fine in this
relationship as long as your wife number
one
or can you be like if you if you want
number two or three are you i think i
could be because the thing is in this
sense like how you're saying you're
you're supposed to
provide and do everything for the woman
and
i
this goes along i was teasing you like
oh because you can't be 300
because you can't be 300
but the thing is if you're if you're
giving what you need to give
because say say um
say if you look at uni
you can pass with a 40. you're not
giving 100 you didn't make a first but
you still pass like you did what you
needed to do to get through so that's
what i'm saying like if you give what
you need to give in that relationship
it'll work yeah but the least i give is
the better for you
in the sense of this girls don't
necessarily like a man that's on them on
them like you know like
it works better when you're on me like
i'm i'm i've got too much i've got not
enough time for you in the sense of in
the perspective of how you see me like
oh he's always busy he's always doing
his thing like every moment that he
spends with me is special because he
just stops like it's
it's better than
it's better for that until the gardener
comes around to do the grass
you know you don't care because you got
two other things in it like you're all
right right you're right your options
are she's gone she's going with the
gardener
you got your two things you got money
she's you don't want to be in this in
the main house all right go in the
gardener's house like go in the pool
house it's up to you like you've got
i'm i'm not just don't let me find it
yeah i'm not okay with men
men forcing women to do things that they
don't want to do but you're the one that
said that you were no no i'm not no no
i'm giving you barriers that if you want
to maintain
then you could be with me if you don't
want to maintain you could be free and
be single or be with someone else that
doesn't have those barriers but i will
guarantee you this the man that doesn't
have the barriers you're not going to be
with him for long because you appreciate
and you love men with barriers bro that
have like restrictions to them that tell
you hey
relax yourself like you know
the house rules like like you can't just
no take your shoes off like what is this
a little idiot but you take your shoes
off though like you know what i'm saying
you have to have certain rules about
amanda even though you don't like it you
love it because it's it's manly it's
like girls they do certain things like
this flipping gal bro but because
they're girls you're like you know
you know they're allowed to get away
with certain things like it's just girls
doing their thing they could talk to you
a certain way like shut up it's like bro
if a man said that i'll box you you know
what but girl would be like i like when
she said that she's cute like you know
what i'm saying yeah okay
i have a question for you right now
would you be able to
have multiple wives
like financially would you be able to
support that's why i'm not multiple
wives so when when do you think that you
will be ready
when i have enough to have multiple
wives trust me they will be there on
deck
and they'll just call them up and be
like now no no
hang on a minute though bro like i'm
gonna push back on that though still
like i i hear you say you know what you
want yeah yeah
but then the question now becomes how
realistic is it very attainable i think
obtainable i think listen i think in two
years time every single person that's
sitting down here is going to be in a
better position in terms of where they
need to be we know where we want to be
at but we'll be in a better position
than we are right now bro you're not
going to be sitting down here with a
hundred thousand subscribers talking
about oh yeah we're in the same position
that we was like no bro i'm saying
you're going to be getting i'm saying
like you'd be better i'll be able to
listen you want to go out shows babes
listen i took
misses on monday you're going tuesday i
can't do that right now be like i'll be
i'll be treating one unfair it would be
like yo i'm giving this one special
treat so do you think that the energy
that you're projecting now though is of
someone that can do it right now
no no
but i have to prepare myself
wait i have a question no if you're
preparing yourself why wouldn't you
start with one because everyone said
earlier that you can't just
start what like okay now i'm gonna have
three wives it's harder it's harder for
me to be with a wife for five years and
then say odd at the end of five years
listen i want a second one and all then
to say all right i'm in a position um
where i need to be in life is either you
follow this how i want my relationship
or not but when you come into this
relationship but i bet you know there'll
be other people there it's different
it's not hard if you
give that image up front you say hey i'm
going to be with you right now but in
time when i'm able to get another wife i
want this to happen but are you going to
are you going to stand for that are you
going to be like
wait
i ride or die no no no no no no i've
ride or died with you i ride or die with
you and then when you get big you now
you want to go for the for for number
two if she
if she wants to be with you and she is
okay with a polyamorous relationship
she's okay like i was the first one
she's gonna be like i was the first one
she's gonna take some pride in that and
if you
put it up front that this is what's
gonna happen i'm with you right now
we're gonna bring somebody in in five
years time whenever however long then if
she's okay with it cool if she's not
obviously you need to find the other
person who is okay with it so do you
want to do that
you see in the western you've seen the
western world yeah you've seen the
western world i think you'll be
hard-pressed to find women that want to
be in
polygamous relations
i'm not saying that i don't i don't
disagree with you right i'm saying in
currently
the women that you find in the western
world are quite selfish if you ask the
average woman they'll be like no that's
my man yeah right that's my man he's
gonna be my man i'm saying maybe
you need to go abroad no that's that's
definitely but i'm saying to you in the
sense of this we know this as men we
have the whole world of women who are
like disposable
that's the wrong word i'm not going to
say disposal i'll say availability like
we have we like women in brazil are
available in 2022 if you want to go to
brazil and i'm saying to you when i'm in
the position where i have oh no a
million in my bank account that's not
going to be a problem for me you really
think you're going to have a million can
i just say yeah listen four of my
brothers and my sisters have a
millionaire a million in their bank
account i'm being real i have seven
sisters like the train station i hunt my
dad my dad is a millionaire i 100
guarantee i will be a millionaire and
it's whether or not you fall in now and
know that i'm going to be polygamous now
or falling later when you know i'm going
to people like this later but have more
money on me could i ever be with it when
i'm trying to get there and have the
respect of do you know what that was my
right to die or you're going to have the
respect she's just here now because i've
got my thing i'll never know if she
wanted me i'll never know if they wanted
me when i didn't have nothing can i just
say
it's a matter of this amount of of of
choices yeah my brother
he's made his decision everything
whether i agree or not i have to
afterwards don't agree i have to respect
now because i'm trying to live my life
differently in it but i wish i respect
one thing i always advocate for everyone
has the freedom to to live their life
the way they the way they want to i just
want to come back um to
to the original question a bit more um
because
this um this question is very um
is very personal to me because i've
actually like lived through this
experience so um
um wait was the question again
so if you have if you have more if
you're making more money
um and your partner
steps out yeah
okay cool so the person that's making
the money making the money if they step
out would you stay with them
okay
so from the time
from the time when i was like 16 yeah
every
every girl every woman i was interested
in i always said to them yeah i'm going
to have a lot of money it's like from 16
i already knew i said i'm gonna have a
lot of money i'm gonna this is what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna have a wonderful life
this than any other so i need you
to i don't
i don't want that to to kind of shake
you you know to kind of like if you
don't i don't come for money
come from very poor background but i
already knew my destiny so
i didn't i don't want someone who's
going to be shaken by that right so with
that being said
i'm now
the breadwinner yeah i'm professional
footballer i'm a keynote speaker i'll do
this that and the other
right
i personally wouldn't make
me personally i personally wouldn't make
the decision to step out right
for me it's been it's been the reversal
when i was with someone yo i was doing
the madness for this person like
spending crazy money
crazy on this person
and then they still cheated
you know what so
now that i'm finished i'll tell you why
after yeah yeah they
they they actually told me that they
want to go with my boy
but um but yeah that's the story for
another thing motion
do you know what's mad do you know why
do you know why because you didn't put
no boundaries on it and you were
spoiling it too much it was probably you
probably put on a pedal store bro
well i should definitely deserve it
brother how can she deserve it and she
cheated on you bro bro it's it's it's
it's crazy but the
that was like that's what's going to say
that you're you're
but dude i just i just want to say like
the the emotional damage that came from
that i remember exactly like when it was
like the 5th of january at 10 22 like
like
10 22.
[Laughter]
10 22 in the big brother house
go on
it was crazy because like i was i was i
was a lot younger and naive then but i
didn't sleep that night i remember it
was like around 3am i was shaking i went
to the living room i was at my parents
house i went to living and mom had to
come out come at the house like yo like
what's going on with you i'm like
and um
how old are we how do we
oh
it happened a couple of times
so the first
the first time it happened
i was in my i was in my late teens i
think
same person right i was the same person
yeah same person you gave her another
chance i gave another chance all right
now about i gave another chance
but the thing you know you it sounds
like even me now it sounds like saying
it sounds like wow men express
themselves why why why did you do that
but you know like
like as a man yeah when you when you
love a woman bro like you wanna like you
wanna do everything for her you go
online you see what what everyone else
is doing for their women and you want
you're trying to you're trying to be
that man you know you're trying to be
that and try try to tell her that listen
i got you no matter what i got you you
know um so
yeah the first time it happened i was
completely heartbroken uh mum came my
mom came to me at 3am like yo what's
wrong with what's wrong with you i told
her what happened everything um
it completely completely broke me but
then i went back to that girl again
you know was she was she a virgin
no she wasn't girl um
at the time she was
and then she cheated
to you at the time
wait wait wait wait i didn't say she had
sex though
well i said she cheated oh she gave me
she gave her oh she had
she had head
anyways um she cheated anyway she
cheated away she didn't louise he said
he's not gonna
i'm gonna
um it happened again so then at this
point i'm just like okay
um enough is enough kind of like i can't
i know that i'm a good brother you know
i know that i'm not i'm not out here
doing the most i'm trying to be i'm
trying to be a good brother so if you
can't respect that then you have to
bounce you have to bounce you know but
my point all my point i'm trying to make
is yeah
everyone has a choice to make right i
made that choice to go back to this
particular somebody
i made a chance to go back to her and
whatever followed followed didn't it so
in everything i was saying here i just
want everyone to to to have this in mind
yeah that
everything that you do you will have a
consequence at the end of it whether you
like it or not everything will have a
consequence so
and you i'm not saying no one should
live the life man because i've i've
lived i've lived my life which brings me
to my point brother like what you said
um what did you say that i'll get eaten
in a second like yeah you're good
okay okay i'm six foot three i'm tall
i'm dark i'm handsome i've i've i've
been
tested bro i've been tested i moved out
my first time moved up my parents house
so 16 yeah right moved to southampton
yeah um i was shocked to take this quick
story yeah i knew that i was 16 um i was
balling
um the team gave me a place
had my own place i had had somewhat of
freedom i had them so we were staying in
what we call digs like if you don't know
football like when you're playing for an
academy show you stay in digs and then
you have like someone that just looks
after you kind of comes around cooks for
you and everything um
kind of yeah but luckily i my mom
already taught me how to do all of that
so she wasn't she didn't need her to
come to come around much um but then um
i had
a group of a particular group of friends
at the time that that were not so good
for me you know just our goals and our
beliefs didn't align so then what they
did is they got
um they they got someone to basically
try to try to to trap me we was talking
about men being trapped um so they said
to her like um
basically go to his place and and try to
you know try to seduce him what not
so um
she came yeah she knocked on the door
and i i knew who she was because we were
all friends at the time
she knocked on the door yeah and
when i say this girl was fire
fit fine
nice length
with the buns everything bruh everything
she was so nice
so she know she knocked to the door i
was trembling i'm like oh my gosh what's
happening here now cause she was dressed
like she was ready to attack yeah so she
was like
you said trembling that's the words you
use i was trembling bro let me i was
trembling
you were probably you were probably like
you would probably like take that
situation take control of the situation
no no no no no no no no i'm just i'm
just like
i'm thinking my lord what's happening
here she came in
walks in remember correctly she walks in
she shuts the door behind her locks and
switches off the light so immediately
yeah you love that in it look at his
waist my brother
eyes closed and everything
um so immediately i knew that okay i'm
in a situation here
i knew that okay i'm in a situation here
obviously um
through the use
kids these days would grow up quickly so
i already knew what was happening but i
didn't know how to deal with at the time
so she came in and they're like yeah
this is what's happening this thing the
other situations of the light and only
only god knows how i got out of that
house imagine like it's my place here
but i leave her in the house and i run
outside yeah
that's that's that that that
all that i'm saying
i hear you
and this is the whole thing is that
this is why i said you're going to get
eaten alive because there's women that
know how to do this type of stuff no no
no i don't think so because if i was to
get if i was to be eaten alive here i
would have been eaten alive because
that's just one example it's happened
multiple times bro like can i speak i
can't let him i'm living
lorry is interesting right
now what happened
on her and he's saying he didn't get run
up on you got run up on bro what galen
want from you is your resources bro like
they don't necessarily want their
phila mignon to be filling me
up
but i'm saying to you well he's but he's
talking about the fact that someone
tried to set
him up essentially
i get that but i'm saying to you there
there necessarily is not okay their game
is not necessarily to to sleep with you
bro they haven't no no they want to
sleep with me they want to sleep with me
um um yeah i ran up the house and um but
my point being that was just one
situation in it because i'm trying to
i'm almost trying to defend myself in a
way where i know that i'm not going to
be eaten i've been with women bro
like if
if i'll show you the women that that
i've been with bro they're they're not
you know i mean they're they're not
those things
the youtubers i can't name them
obviously the big personalities like
my question is though so why would you
go for that type of woman knowing the
type of man that you are i was young bro
right i was young but that's the thing
that i was young i had this this um
narrative of of of of how i wanted to
live my life and my thing is yeah i'm
thinking to myself i'm gonna be a big
star i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do that
i want someone that comes from from from
from that background as well yeah but
the thing is with in wanting that you
have to know that this person there's
there's nothing wrong with having
someone that's that's in the same field
domain as you're never in the bush
go on fine
i
my point is yes good point fair point i
could my point is nothing wrong with
going with that kind of caliber of women
yeah but um it's more about the the
person's um characteristics traits yeah
because people look at me and i'm i'm so
tired of like speaking about this and
defending but i have to continue doing
this because the first thing whenever i
went through years
wait i'm trying to think of the timeline
now i went through a period yeah where i
just couldn't i came off social media
came on social media um delayed all my
accounts because it just it just got
ridiculously too much yeah and i got to
a point where like every time i had to
defend myself like whenever i told
someone like i'm a footballer if i tell
if i meet a woman i was like okay what
do you do for a living i say i'm a
footballer immediately i'm cancelled
because they know that football is at
this football is a um for indian america
are you serious mm-hmm not professional
professional i played four links i've
seen gibraltar prem
what abroad abroad yeah
i live in spain oh you live in spain
okay
so you're in the la liga
uh
now now i live in spain last year i was
playing in japan that's in japan i was
living and playing in japan oh okay yeah
but now i'm in um uh i'm in the middle
of getting a transfer um which i can't i
don't think i'm not right you're like
saying all right i'm not going to say
right now but um but yeah if you follow
me on socials and you'll follow my
journey um
um point being is like i always felt as
if i had to like defend myself all the
time like okay although
this is what i do for a living because
this is not what this is not who i feel
as a known host bro exactly exactly
sadly a lot a lot of um
athletes in general man a lot of
athletes have have the way they've been
depicted the media is not very pleasant
so those of us who are trying to change
the narrative we have a very very
difficult task because it's hard to find
someone that will then believe you the
same way that i shared my secret head
and
you know what i mean because it's like
no no way it can't be sold but point
being it is so so in in
in that regard you have to
more so focus on the person's
personality the characteristic traits
the values the morals and what they
stand for instead of how much they make
and all that other rare that comes with
bro that sounds poetic you may you make
me want to take no take you under my
wing bro
i'll go wait oh
what i'm saying because i'm a little bit
older like i think i'm the oldest person
here like how do you hold it i don't
look it
cheese i might be the oldest person i
might be the only other best friend
right i'm 41. and you said you're 25.
i'm 25 yeah yeah bro you got a lot to
learn brother
i'm never gonna lie like bro
you're a football player bro you're good
you're like you're like especially where
you're gonna go bro you're gonna end up
as one of the top 10 percent of men from
yeah obviously your mentality might be
different might be like you know yeah
you want to stay monogamous and whatnot
blah blah blah but a lot of girls are
going to come for you fam john decided
radio bro exactly whoa
yeah a lot of girls are going to come
for you bro and
you need to understand how girls are
especially in 2022 bro that like they're
different broth they're different and i
know for you to find
for you to be like oh yeah needle in a
haystack business
who who are you to say that he doesn't
know how women are just because he
hasn't he hasn't engaged with women the
way you have he's engaged he's engaged
with women probably the same way you
have just sex hasn't been a factor yeah
because i think women are different
thank you that's 100 when you're having
sex with them
it's different to when you're just
chilling with them because they get my
ties that exactly
from my experience and looking at and
hearing your story yeah
your spirit yeah seems to be a little
bit you got like a pure spirit yeah i'm
saying like you've got a pure spirit
yeah me
yeah and you and
it's kind of wait wait what do you think
pure spirits in the world that we live
in they
listen bro
people will
because what happens is right
is that
you walk out with your pure spirit yeah
into the world with it and the world
shows you
[ __ ] this pure
[ __ ]
like and the thing is and i think and
the thing is i'm not saying the world is
correct i'm saying that your spirit
essentially is the way people should be
in general do you get what i'm saying
but the world in which you live in bro
like like like i said to you you bro
yeah you might have to go um you might
have to go abroad yeah you bro you can't
go to the bush you might have to go
somewhere to find that girl with the
same pure spirit as you bro because you
need to get an untouched woman because
it seems like
your soul is untouched and the thing is
i don't want to um diminish untouched
souls because i think the reason why
untouched souls exist is to kind of
remind us
of how things could be yeah yeah i'm
saying that you you are here to remind
no no seriously
it's not how i am right but i'm saying
right
it's not how i am but your spirit is to
remind us how things could be yeah do
you know what i'm saying and so if you
disneyland right because that's why
people go to disneyland because it
reminds us how great things are we have
these things in society that remind us
how great things are when and then we've
got to go back to our [ __ ] job and
there's like all right and then we get
you might need to go somewhere to find
the same spirit as you because the
bottom line is in this world in this
what this world is savage
it's savage out here and the thing is
that's what i said you'll get eaten
alive okay
sorry i'll add to that one thing i will
say is for me the best thing you should
do is to seek counsel from guys that are
wiser or older who have been through the
game uh before you make
moves like
finding that specific goal that's why
sorry to call you that's why my two best
friends yeah shout out join joanna darko
love you joe see you friday and never
smebu yeah um they're ones and joe's in
her 40s and never turning 40
respectively like these guys
and and women they're 15 years ahead of
me so
um the same way i kind of feel like i
have guidance in that in that regard
um
and another thing personally personally
for me is i stay prayed up because like
you say there's vultures
vultures everywhere so i know what i
have to do to kind of like maintain like
what i have to do and i'm not going to
lie to you brother it's hard bro
there are times
there are times when well actually i
even asked myself why am i doing this
like this is this is long like i could
be like like like like like like a
majority of people and kind of um kind
of live a different life but let me tell
you the time the one time that i tried
it almost lost my life and i was like
nah the same for me so that's why i
respect everyone's journey i respect
what everyone's on and um yeah just
stick to your truth really um this will
be my last comment and then we'll read
some super chats and then we'll get last
remarks and then we'll wrap it up um
i
do i do believe that there are women out
here who may have
done what they want to do live their
life but deep down inside they may be
looking for someone like you someone
that has all the values like you do i'm
not saying that it's a broad
a broad spectrum but there are women out
here who
now now that they've done all they've
done whatever they're like i really i
ain't about that life no more i really
want someone who deep down inside has
the same values and same morals as i do
even though i
may not be as pure as they are but i
want to still be
basically equally yolked in that in like
other areas so there are women out there
who are looking for guys like you so
don't let these don't let these lots
change yeah
i'm kidding love the brothers man the
leftovers are for you love the brothers
the leftovers after she's been through
me she go to you oh my dad
i've abused her and brings her out she
goes to you bro because you're
vulnerable and you're going through all
right i'm going to treat her right and
all of that all right guys this guy's
just going to read last week we got a
super chat and we got a
reference um
up north society said oh they donated 14
thank you um
pearl uber from airport so they tell
them pearl to get here um
there was three super chats sent in by
the same person and i don't know the
last one is i life i don't know how to
say your first name um
but collectively this person sent in
40 pounds 40 pounds
love and dance emoji so um info vector
sent twenty dollars a huge factor in why
dating is failing today is that men are
desperate and naive while women are
delusional and entitled does the panel
understand how this dynamic feeds itself
to get worse
so all right
nat
nat p
says um
they donated five dollars uh fax we have
a we have a group of friends and ain't
no such thing as a best friend of
opposite sex
that's what that person says
um
sir
or siri
um i don't know
aji bola there we go
um donated five dollars he said yellow
shirt g correct all you need is cash be
completely honest confident and have the
moolah and take control
thank you
so
house of hass donated ten dollars um the
way we talk about cheating is childish
if someone is cheating there is a lack
for men is mainly a dead bedroom or
women gets fats or falls off
falls off for women it's emotional
uh hypergamy pick well
um
next person just
just human oh i like the way i spelled
it h-u-e-m-a-n
twenty dollars
they donated um to the man in the yellow
jess said it's not hard with one woman
at first if you tell her what you want
in the future your response was will she
go for that you said you don't want to
control a woman so tell them and let her
choose
nope
i love you i love it i love i love how
you feel all right um tim donated twenty
dollars uh
yes
tim neruth uh the footballer what do you
know about it he said
all right
he said the footballer bro trust me
um of your christian if you're a
christian or if you're a christian get a
christian woman those type of women want
to build a relationship like you and me
i found one that i found one that's pure
like me and it's been heaven since where
did you find her come tell me where you
found her tim tell her where you found
her all right last one doug mpa
um donated ten dollars guy come guy
complaining about being a footballer
makes me sick eighty percent of men go
go no get no attention at all stop
whining and enjoy it just just no babies
and no
marriage jess is the best
oh thank you
um last one sorry tim another one twenty
dollars and from that and from what i've
said isn't easier isn't easier said than
done it takes patience and time for the
right one to come along and
enter your life don't be eager to find
the right one when you're working on
yourself is when she finds you
those are all the super chats thank you
guys for the super chats we appreciate
it hey all the donations go to
um buy new equipment there's some new
updates y'all are going to see them soon
so thank you for the super chat so
we're going to go around and just give
our final thoughts of what you think
about what we talked about today and
then we'll wrap it up
thanks for watching
um yeah i enjoyed this conversation uh i
i love and appreciate everybody's
opinion and uh
it was good fun it was good fun diving
with everyone uh and i'd love to come
back yeah
i'm just gonna say
just pearly has not got enough um
youtube followers you don't need to
follow her so you guys subscribe to this
thing i'm saying get it to a million you
know what i'm trying to say she needs it
that you're not saying push the channel
because we're out here we all love each
other we might have different opinions
but we're trying to push it let's get it
are you trying to talk
that was a really really good ending
speech no it's been um it's been really
insightful and actually it's really nice
listening to everyone's opinion because
ultimately it's down
to you being happy isn't it and your
happiness one life to live so be happy
speak your truth but just don't
compromise anyone else's happiness um
just ensure that you're you're being
your true authentic self
100
um
my takeaway is just tell the truth like
you can go so far with the truth like
you you can find in this world you can
find anything that you're looking for
i'm so serious like anything you can
think of you can find it if you look
hard enough yeah the truth will take you
so far
you're just you're just tired of him
lying in it
um
no i love the show today i'm very
insightful um love all the guest panels
um i think
if i can say one last thing it's just um
similar to what everyone said really
like more or less just stick to your
truth um respect everyone else's opinion
as well like no one has to not everyone
has to live their life the way you live
life you know um but yeah let's try not
to cheat people thank you
um yeah folks you guys already know me
already um i've been hosting pearls here
you know what i'm saying um i've been
hosting for the past two weeks um
i would just say this listen like you
said like share and subscribe to both
pearl and myself
and
i think just done a great uh great
hosting
come on jess thank you thank you i
appreciate it
and um yeah same thing live your truth
and the things will come if you're
truthful from the beginning i think um
you'll be very surprised as to the
things that will actually come towards
you i think personally lying
um is a detriment to both you and the
person that you're that you're with
and
it's and the thing is for your mental
health it's easier to tell the truth
and get what you want than it is to lie
and try and be dodging and ducking and
diving so
same thing tell the truth be yourself
be good to yourselves and each other
[Music]
if you guys enjoyed this um enjoy the
podcast it's only right that you
subscribe and follow and all of that
good stuff too
of course
um as to wrap it up now as well
um it's been very entertaining and
insightful um but i'll stand on the
point where you can't have your cake in
here too before what i'm saying if you
want something then act accordingly if
you don't
and you still expect that same outcome
then you're the fall at the end of the
day in it if the shoe fits then the shoe
fits in it i'm not forgetting anybody
but you know what i'm saying what sizing
brother all these conclusions directed
at me though
obviously the shoe fits the shoe fits
you for what i'm saying can't feel the
type of way if it don't fit you um but
yeah that's me
[Music]
so um it's been it's been great having
you all here thank you all for coming on
the show i appreciate it it's been fun
we had laughs serious conversation it's
been great it's always great and then
for all of you at home if you haven't
liked comment and subscribed yet do that
now and if you have not subscribed and
you've seen one or two more videos we
got beef we all said in the beginning
don't need to repeat it again just
subscribe it doesn't take away from your
life it adds to your life i promise you
so without that
we are all done thank you for coming
thank you for watching and we'll see you
next time